bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais
accueillir au de favre de la chaîne au
de what the fuck journalistes et du cou
youtube est ce que tu peux commencer par
un peu te présenter dans ton parcours
moi je suis quelqu'un qui ne se
prédestinait pas spécialement être
journaliste à la base moi je voulais je
voulais aider les gens c'est pas
possible de ne pas aider les gens qu
enfin je sais pas bon ben j'ai toujours
ce truc c'est toujours très sensible
très aidé restaurer ou alors les animaux
ou alors les bébés dauphins bp vous des
gens ou mon voisin aider sa superbe et
toujours jusqu'à un mot tu te dire de
quoi
mais scarlett a toujours dit tu t'es
toujours dit ça depuis que tu es tout
petit tout genre tu te dis ah non moi je
vais toujours moi je je je je pleurais
de hand et oui j'ai fait toujours très
sensible aux animaux et tout ça tue
toujours aidé et je sais pas monter je
voulais être bonne soeur ma mère tu
aimerais qu'on presse aps
bon j'ai changé d'avis quand même à
l'adolescence bizarrement mais non
et j'avais je m'étais dit tiens
d'humanitaires et tout ça donc que j'ai
fait sciences po je voulais faire de
l'humanitaire
j'ai fait un parti au pérou faire un
espèce de stage militaire mais en fait
ça m'a pas ça m'a pas absolue ce n'est
pas branché puis surtout en fait pour
faire l'humanitaire faut être manuel
quoi comme si tu veux vraiment être
utile aux gens sauf que moi vraiment
heureusement que j'ai vite fait un
cerveau parce que je sais rien faire
mais je sais bien ce voyage-là en vrai
je les ai je sais pas si on peut citer
des mains non les déplacés des plats
surgelés
moi c'est ce que je ne sais pas faire
une omelette s'te plaît donc et voilà et
donc j'ai dit mince mince mince que
vais-je donc faire je sais écrire un peu
et donc là j'ai dit bon ok peut-être
journalistes et est donc c'est comme ça
que finalement ça m'est venu mais
c'était pas un truc où je rêvais de
faire ça depuis que le petit est tout et
puis après pour aller rapidement donc
j'ai j'ai bossé en radio radio caraïbes
international c'était mon premier boulot
c'est génial parce que là-bas aux
antilles en martinique radio si tu viens
de 4 radio caraïbes international tu es
un dieu vivant quoi enfin j'exagère un
peu mais c'est hyper fan ou hyper
populaire dans la dombes grosse classe
et puis énergie aussi énergie antilles
j'avais jamais la voix qui dit toute
l'actu avec autres femmes et les
meilleurs et artisanal puissance 14 ans
je dis pas qu'il ya pas eu de fait knut
qui s'est fait notre sport tu t'égares à
écouter non j'avais j'avais même un
j'avais même le soir tu sais ils font
les vibrantes haine mais où tu
conseilles un peu des trucs tu vois les
histoires de coeur et les machins moment
donné j'ai fait ça fonctionne pas et
genre animatrice tu sais bon bref
et puis et puis après j'ai fait une
école de journalisme en alternance
s'appelle le cfpj à paris en alternance
avec i télé c'était l'enfer parce que i
télé à midi dans un placard total je
faisais de lentilles journalisme c'est à
dire que en fait j'étais je faisais même
pas de sujet
en fait tu peux dans les chaînes d'info
tu peux soit allé sur le terrain
donc ça c'est bien que comptant en
général alors moi c'était absolument pas
ça qu'on me faisait faire de le le
niveau entre me met un peu en dessous
que je suis en c'est de faire du desk du
day c'est à dire qu'en fait tu reçois
les images des gens qui sont son terrain
et toi tu met en forme et c'est avec les
informations mais du coup tu quittes pas
le bureau mais si j'avais fait ça ça
aurait été déjà génial mois en fait que
je faisais s'te plaît
c'était je rentrais les les conducteurs
des jt en gros tu as un conducteur de
taxi théâtre les quarts d'heure il a
invité dans ses troupes la lettonie
garde heurte à tous les journalistes
qu'elle est à dire alors moi mon sujet
il fait 2 minutes 30 la balle le mien il
fait une 37 à valmy effet machin est en
fait tu dois te organisé pour que ça
dépasse pas le jt chemin il fallait pas
suivre donc c'était ça pendant deux ans
c'est ça que j'ai fait j'avais envie de
mourir mais je me suis quand même
accroché tu as eu bizarrement et après
j'ai trouvé une société de production
qui travaille pour différentes chaînes
qui s'appelait kamikaze qui
malheureusement n'est plus la kamikaze
production et cette société de
production bam a permis enfin de faire
un peu de terrain ce n'était cité qu'il
se montait donc c'est les meilleurs
plans parce qu'en fait du coup il ya
tout à faire et pitrem allemands ils ont
besoin de toi pour faire ceci et cela et
c'était un peu au four et au moulin et
et là j'ai fait ou à des sujets pour
beaucoup de sujets pour 66 minutes de m6
beaucoup de sujets pour mais c'était
quand même il y avait beaucoup de cd
petite enquête c'est pas enfin voilà 7
c'était quand même assez fins et c'est
d'ailleurs ça l'est peut-être toujours
pas je peux regarder l'émission depuis
des années mais est assez exigeant quand
même et puis voilà sur des sujets divers
et variés j'avais j'avais qu'aux
enquêtes et d envoyé spécial j'avais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait des lois du zone
interdite du un peu de tout un peu et
puis après le mieux je suis parti de
27.2 là j'ai fait un grand doc qui m'a
vraiment kevala remarqué sur
l'expérimentation animale pour canal+
c'était vraiment une enquête enquête
enquêtait sur le modèle animal est ce
qu'il est pertinent
hier jour qu'on a dit il faut que je la
mette sur youtube s'être plaints parce
que j'étais extrêmement fier de ça et
et puis et puis un mode doc après sur
nuit debout lui de bouc mais assez
intéressé voilà et après j'ai décidé de
créer ma chaîne voilà pardon de c'est
parfait résumé tout ce que je sais pas
quel est le temps qu on a un père 25
minutes sur des trucs qu'on n'a pas
forcément hyper intéressant enfin c'est
toi qui m'a lancé en même temps on a le
temps voit l'arrivée du pied danser il
ya deux ans deux ans un peu plus
compliqué quand tu t'es dit je lancé ma
chaîne j'en avais marre de d'être
commentaires de bosser comme une malade
mais c'est dur de trouver des faits
d'être journaliste et ses toiles enfume
a toujours tourné en panique dans le
monde entier parce que personne ne
comprend ce qui se passe et personne
c'est à qui se fier que c'est un métier
extrêmement dur que je fais vraiment eu
tellement de coeur est tellement de mai
comme d'ailleurs tous les genres est ce
que je connais vraiment quoi et
qu'est-ce qui est souvent sous payés
nalin et et par dessus ça les gens te
déteste et par dessus ça donc tu fais un
espèce de service public quelque part
aux gens ouais mais il te le rendent
mais ce même pas qu'ils lui rendent pas
c'est qu'il faut il te dit il faut que
désire et par dessus ça il ya eu
l'apparition un peu dans cette année là
en tout cas c'est là que a prêché
invités ça que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
vraiment un sacré paquet de gens qui
surfait sur cet échantillon analystes
qui pour raconter n'importe quoi pour
vendre leurs sauces et qui était souvent
le plus populaire que les journalistes
eux-mêmes donc ça faisait un peu
beaucoup pour moi et donc vraiment c'est
un espèce de ras-le-bol quoi et et trump
aussi qui m'a qui m'a plongé dans une
profonde qui me penche toujours dans une
profonde eux j'aime pas comment
expliquer c'est pas une certain je vais
dire méditation et cie si c'était ça
dans un je ne sais pas mais il faut pas
trop je réfléchisse à sa sinon je vais
pleurer mais j'ai dit bon aude écoute tu
as les moyens de combattre un petit peu
l'effet que news en tout cas de d d un
peu les gens ont toujours cette idée
d'aidé
parce que des fois encore tu es
journaliste je te demande aussi mine de
rien est ce que tu es tu vraiment est-ce
que tu prends vraiment service public
que nous se retrouve à faire des faits
divers des trucs j'ai envoyé pas
l'utilité moi ça me saoule est grave
quand tu fais un enfin quand c'est du
magazine qui passe quand même trois mois
de ta vie là dessus et tu es obligé de
te passionné un minimum pour le sujet
parce que sinon le toutes sortes tu vois
une chose que je plonge de web et à la
fin tu te dis mais en fait ça a servi à
quoi bon
ouais mais et donc j'avais besoin aussi
de ressentir un concept utilisé là et je
savais que j'avais je pouvais voir mon
site et là dessus et je savais que que
que j'en avais marre et que j'avais
envie un peu de voix là de rendre un peu
au journalisme ces quelques lettres de
noblesse si tu veux voilà on va dire ça
alors je dis pas que je le fais
d'ailleurs et c'est à queue mais s'était
séparé sorte que c'était l'idée de base
c'était de dire mais mais des fois je me
dis mais les gars c'est quoi on va faire
une semaine sans journalistes nulle part
on va voir si vous allez être contents
non mais tu vois là je sais pas quoi en
fait les gens rient c'est hyper
important
je sais pas que de que c'est génial et
c'est enfin que tout que tout le monde
fait un boulot super mais des fois les
gens se rendent pas compte en fait enfin
l'accès à l'info la route quel d'avoir
une info qualité savoir ce qui se passe
dans un monde s'est pas donné dans tous
les pays enfin tu vois et c'est dur et
ses fermes en bref donc donc un peu tout
s'est tu vois un espèce de truc un peu
multi combat qui a fait que j'ai quitté
ma j'ai créé ma chaîne à la fois pour
populariser un petit peu de journalisme
à la fois pour lutter comme pour lutter
contre compte l'effet que nous éduquer
un petit peu
tant que je peux faire quoi les gens
pour les aiguilles etc
et puis aussi je me suis dit tiens je
veux à l'époque en tout cas j'avais vu
aucun journaliste qui enquêtait sur
youtube est en revanche beaucoup de
faits coeur j'ai dit allons un peu les
titiller sur leur terrain quoi ça peut
être marrant toi tu regrette pas non pas
du tout mais alors ce que j'adore
surtout c'est vraiment marrant parce que
c'est vraiment une aventure en fait
c'est ça que j'aime finalement ce que
j'ai commencé ça n'importe comment sans
fin je sais pas je n'ai pas de plan
celui ait pas de défendre bien fait
c'est quoi ta cible avant moi je fais
pas je serai pas mal doublage et passifs
c'est ce qu'ont ceux qui trouvent ça
bien c'est le mât cible non mais je suis
pas du tout dans ce truc de marketing de
farbus enfin bref c'est pas d'ailleurs
ça veut pas dire franchement que c'est
péjoratif mais voilà je partais un peu
comme ça n'importe comment les parents
je vous les reproduire sur quelque chose
je n'ai plus en tête
voilà j'ai des blancs bruns
régulièrement qui débute sa valeur en
tant que tu avais fléchi fait soit c'est
l'autre c'est un truc qui était assez
récurrent france je pense que j'ai
beaucoup de gens qui sont sur youtube
bah en fait identifié la cible à avoir
une stratégie marketing et tout va c'est
pas du tout la manière dont ces devis
mutuelle bah je sais pas quoi
enfin j'aimerais bien moi je si
quelqu'un veut faire une étude de marché
et sur l'étude de marché n'est pas tant
de la sphère jeu mais qu'il était loin
de bordel le besoin est là si l'idée
c'était de savoir s'ils avaient un
besoin si je pouvais répondre à un
besoin je crois que oui mais je pense
qu'après deux jours sont élancés sur
youtube on peut revoir
bon voila j'ai envie de faire ça c'est
et puis après ils ont découvert qu'il
avait des gens qui arrivent à garder ok
donc c'est un mépris comme ouais c'est
ça voilà du coup lui le journaliste je
pense que ça les conditions du travail
de journaliste de sont devenues plus
difficiles avec le temps que ça toujours
été
alors après moi ça fait dix ans qu'ils
travaillent donc j'ai pas non plus un
recul de fou mais mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que là par exemple j'ai bu un
bouquin dernièrement je peux pas c'est
ce qui s'appelle ses comptes
journalistes elle explique à quel point
enfin la folie du truc c'est à dire que
tu as des gens qui se retrouvent enfin
même mois on va pouvoir
cependant l'exemple à moi comme ça ça va
ça va être ça va être plus simple mais
typiquement quand on veut faire du dock
par exemple d'aider des sujets pour des
miles mais même sur magazine que tout le
monde connaît et c est bien c'est quoi
le process il faut que tu aies une idée
une fois que tu as ton idée on va te
dire creuse l'a écrit non un truc et
seras-tu va l'envoyer à la prod ils vont
te dire demain mercredi a quand même
parce que finalement ça on sait pas
encore donc en fait tu te retrouves à
près enquêté pendant des fois des
semaines sur un sujet sans savoir du
tout s'il va être pris par exemple tu
vois et mais combien de fois ça m'est
arrivé d'avoir bossé deux mois sur un
sujet auquel je croyais j'ai écrit
toiture en panneaux dedans machin ton
truc
et puis on te dit ah bah pas de chance
en fait la semaine dernière
il ya un sujet un peu similaire qui est
passé donc mais peut-être pour l'année
prochaine tu vois et pendant ce temps là
c'est comment tu vis en fait c'est quoi
ton tu vois enfin je crois que les
conditions pour l'emploi elles sont
encore chez pai a eu un article à ces
derniers temps qui font que j'ai vu
passer des trucs ne plus passer
ddd statut de votre journaliste
complètement alarmé par la nouvelle
réforme fait pôle emploi etc
mais c'est c'est c'est un métier où en
fait tu te tue je parle même pas des
grands reporters pour moi j'ai des gens
qui partent sans assurance sans rien
parce que ça coûte trop cher allez dans
les pires conflits qui c'est qui qui qui
sait pas à qui tu es le journal d
hachette
je sais pas enfin achète pour un prix
dérisoire quads et des papiers qui tique
qu'ils ont rédigé pour presque au risque
de leur vie tu vois ce que je te dis
mais c'est ça et ça au niveau jaune
explique bien ca ca c'etait pas il ya 15
ans c'était pas du tout comme ça en fait
tu vas et tu sais je sais pas il ya un
espèce de truc qui fait que les
conditions elles se sont elles se sont
archi dégradé quoi et moi je juge en
tout cas ce qui me gênait pas fait
d'études longues sur le sujet et c'est
sûr je peux pas te je fais juste devenu
mon cas personnel à moi je sais pas dans
quelle mesure ils représentatifs mais en
tout cas je peux te dire que il ya un
gros malaise dans la profession on va
tous les tous mes potes etc sont
heureusement qu'ils aiment l'art et
essieux parce que parce que c'est parce
qu'en fait tu t'es c'est-à-dire dur d'en
vivre quoi vraiment vraiment dur donc
donc voilà c'est c'est très compliqué
puis voilà tu rajoutes enfin on te
demande de faire des enquêtes hyper
londres en trois jours non ça n'existe
pas mais du coup si tu la situe la bac
les mains ça va être enfin ça va être
tu te retrouves prix en fait entre plein
des taux c'est à dire que à la fois tu
ne te donne pas les moyens de faire son
travail correctement tué quelque part
obligé de céder sur soi bas ça tu l'as
pas forcément bien vérifier où ça tu
l'as pas parce que en fait c'est dans
une course au temps parce que tu as
deadline de fou parce que et ça
m'interroge vachement ce système là
parce que je pense que je pense qu'en
fait part c'est mon sentiment à moi mais
je pense que les gens nous attendent il
ya une vraie crise ne faut pas se cacher
le cacher dans la profession mais je
pense que les gens nous attendent
justement sur ces sujets dont la que
personne parce que sur césarienne faire
la course avec twitter ou de la coupe ça
à tous et à un peu à l'échalote à celui
qui sort le 1er le truc et c'est
d'ailleurs on se prend les pieds dans le
tapis voilà mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on vraiment qu'on fasse peut-être
moins de sujets moins de voix là mais
plus plus en profondeur enfin tout cas
moi c'est ce à quoi j'aspire c'est ce à
quoi je crois qu'à moi dans mes années
tous les journalistes aspirent surtout
le métier pour sa voix sauf que c'est
c'est tellement dur et c'est tellement
et les conditions sont pas bonnes et
puis et puis des cases pour faire
banquette il n'a pas beaucoup en france
dégâts lorsque j'appelle des cases cdd
par exemple complément d'enquêté c'est
une case envoyé spécial c'est une autre
case mais il y en a pas beaucoup avant
il y avait pas mal
avait un peu un canal moi je mon esprit
l'expérimentation image-là effet à
canal+ bref bout lors il est parti la
raser ce même pas d'investir 1,6 à
l'info quasiment il ya je ne sais plus
encore j'ai plus en tête mais
régulièrement comme ça moi je suis
abonné à plein de haplin de newsletters
et ses journalistes est régulièrement
déplore bas que et soit ya moins de
budget alloué pour tel ou tel 4
investigations soient finalement il ya
une attaque à tarification qui disparaît
c'est donc donc c'est super facile et
donc les écoutes faut que les gens qui
se rendent compte de ça avant de dire
les font de la merde les journalistes
etc
c'est quand même enfin c'est comme tout
cas après le jugement intempestifs là
j'ai un peu du mal faudrait que les gens
se mettent un peu de basket et je dis
pas ça pour me dédouaner moi
personnellement de quoi que ce soit ou
des douaniers qui que ce soit de voies
de fait rien dire que c'est génial ce
qu'on fait est que voilà mais il faut
comprendre en fait c'est pas trop dur je
pense que c'est lié au sein du cs
dégradés ou sézanne soissons qui a
bordeaux sociaux ou fait qu'internet
promeuvent de plus en plus leurs
activités dans l'instantanéité
je sais pas exactement à quoi c'est
l'ailier je serai curieuse d'avoir de
pain pareil dans ma to do list
il ya écrit en rouge me renseigner sur
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on en est là donc
c'est terrain c'était même un docu que
je voulais faire peut-être que je le
ferais un jour avant même de fait ma
chaîne youtube j'avais brancher un
copain qui maintenant est rédacteur en
chef sur les what the fuck là depuis que
temps et s'appelle sylvain lemay et
c'est lui qui a fait qui a réalisé un
super sujet lent que sa conviction sur
les enfants se les enfants placés bref
et en fait
et en fait on voulait déjà il ya
quelques années faire un sujet même pour
nous pour comprendre comment on en est
arrivé là
qu'est-ce qui fait enfin explorer un peu
cette défiance entre les journalistes et
net-citoyens on va dire c'est une
journée sont des citoyens bref vous
m'avez compris et je le sais pas pas un
joueur je pense qu'il ya plein de
boulettes ont été faites et dans tous
les sens et tout le temps quand les
journalistes donc je dirais qu on peut
se dire des fois ils ont cherché je sais
pas quoi là mais peut-être pas à ce
point pour que pour que la défense soit
à ce point
donc je je ne sais pas vraiment c'est
une question tu vois je
je sais qu'il ya quelqu'un qui s'appelle
julia cagé croire donc professeur
d'économie à sciences po paris
voilà tu vois là et elle a écrit à fond
sur l'économie des médias
là je vois par exemple sur son twitter
et donc il ya trois thés livre il ya le
prix de la démocratie sauver les médias
et l'information à tout prix et je sais
que l
à chaque fois que j'ai essayé de creuser
justement sur mais quel est le problème
2 2 enfin quelle crise on traverse
quelque part surtout économiquement elle
elle est dans l est et en tout les
petits donc pareil c'est quelqu'un que
j'aimerais bien rencontrer un de ces
quatre pour essayer de comprendre en
fait et notamment elle soutenait une
initiative que je trouve tort qu'ils
s'appellent disclose sais pas si tu sais
ce que se disent claude c'est en fait un
collectif journalistes qui sont
entièrement financés par des dons et ils
ont sorti ce qu avait sorti les les
affaires déjà mme labrie yémen et qui te
voilà disclose ses premiers médias
d'investigation à but non lucratif et
dire tout est à la fois un média est une
ong est en fait l'idée c'est vraiment 50
est sortie ça disent que ça va vachement
intéressé parce que donc l'idée c'est
simplement de deux comme c'est comme de
crohn des quads et des grosses enquêtes
en fait tu montes mais je sais que
du coup julia cagé soutenez salle était
à la soirée de lancement etc
je n'ai pas pu y être mais voilà il ya
deux façons il ya encore une fois moi je
crois encore hier on a invité un cru que
repenser les médias
o pour le siècle à venir etc enfin tout
le monde c'est pour un peu branle bas de
combat danger les journalistes pour
savoir mais où on va qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans quelle direction avec quel
argent surtout parce que j'étais à
lausanne il ya quelques temps d'ailleurs
et un diktat des journalistes là bas
j'ai plus les chiffres en tête mais il
montre l effondrement des recettes mais
un truc de malade quoi bas des recettes
que ce soit pour les journaux pour la
télé et c'est parce que maintenant mais
il préfère et c'est pas d'ailleurs ali a
par un jugement mais je sais pas avec
internet et tout les recettes
publicitaires elles ont partagé les
influenceurs j'ai une machin et tous et
souvent enfin j'imagine plus payant que
que parmalat en fait le marché devenu
tellement énorme la publicité que il ya
un effondrement des recettes
publicitaires donc super compliqué quoi
donc je n'ai pas la réponse exacte à
cette question de qu'est ce qui se passe
mais il est un comment en est on arrivé
là mais j'aimerais bien l'avoir
ouais il ya des contraintes budgétaires
plus forte et des conditions de travail
plus compliqué mais oui et puis après
ouais mais quand il sera elle plus
compliqué d tu te retrouves à tu te
retrouves à la fin je veux pas mettre à
place de jaude journal est alors oui il
soit une chose cloche
tu vas me paraît donc quand on me
demandait les journalistes qu'est ce
qu'on fait les journées je n'arrive pas
à parler vraiment au nom des
journalistes parce qu'en fait c'est une
telle il ya une telle variété de genres
tu vois là j'allais parler par exemple
pour la fpt j'allais dire oui il ya la
fp tu te retrouves à blanc fait j'en
sais rien allez fais tu te retrouves à
quoi un homme en fait ce que je veux
dire c'est que j'ai c'est que les ça me
tue toujours quand je vois les gens dire
ah oui les journalistes ceci est
journaliste cela mais moi qui suis à
l'intérieur du milieu depuis dix ans je
suis incapable de sortir une seule un
seul trait sur qui serait commun à tous
les journaleux 35 mille journalistes de
france et cette fermeture c'est
tellement c'est ça n'a pas de sens
finalement de mettre les gens dans le
même dans le même
actu c'est pas du tout pareil si moscou
fait pas à moi c'était localier à la
dépêche
a toulouse je pense que tu bosses pas
exactement pareil tu as pas les mêmes
enjeux que moi sur ma chaîne youtube qui
ai moi-même n'est pas les mêmes enjeux
du tout que c'est pas quelqu'un qui tape
au figaro dentelle ces experts celui n'y
a pas de cas par un jour tu voire un
brin fils c'est quelque chose de
tellement tellement tellement variés
donc j'ai du mal à voir moi-même à
m'exprimer un peu a pour toute la
profession c'est moi je peux juste par
les plombs mais pour le secteur un petit
peu que je connais qui est donc les
secteurs youtube même si le secteur
magazine télé magazine donc tous les
compléments enquête
envoyé spécial les les accessits et cela
va cesser c'est ça que j'ai fait moi je
peux parler un petit peu de ça mais bon
jour il n'y avait pas de trous
d'interaction entre différents
journalistes au dessus en vidéo 2 pas
tellement
pas tellement après moi je suis
quelqu'un qui résonne pas du tout donc
enfin j'aime pas ça ce jeu là mais c
vrai ke
après quand tu as des mots mais tout ça
vient aussi un peu plus compliqué ce que
veut le faire il faut arriver mais non
mais je toute façon que ce soit dans le
journalisme ou dans d'autres milieux
j'ai jamais aimé un peu cet aspect un
peu je sais pas c'est un peu fort comme
terme mais consanguins non mais c'est
que ce truc où on va j'aime trop respiré
rencontrer d'autres gens qu aucun
rapport avec mon milieu etc
j'aime j'aime pas trop et de mets donc
comme dans tous les milieux yaya c'était
ça y est c'est tout là où on voit là on
est parfois peut-être un peu trop en bas
de clôture
ouais et donc est donc en fait j'ai du
coup je connais pas moi même enfin jeu
que j'ai plein de potes journalistes etc
mais je sais pas non plus en voilà un
réseau de jeux cultive pas un réseau de
fou parmi les journalistes etc
donc mais c'est vrai qu'en tout cas
entre par exemple ceux qui font de la
presse écrite et de la télé il ya pas
beaucoup de passerelles
enfin y'a pas beaucoup de pascal je veux
dire on moi par exemple dans mes dix ans
de carrière j'ai jamais rencontré un
journaliste se passe
ouais non mais tu vois non c'est vrai
les journalistes radio non plus je crois
pas je vais rencontrer c'est dire si ba
dégâts mais quand même changé avoue
enfin physiquement à peut-être tu veux
aller soirée de loin on soit dans la
nuit j'avais un mec qui produit des
chips qui posait à france inter si j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais farce et enfin en
fait c'est pas ça soit on part d'une
profession où il ya encore une fois
35000 personnes et dans des médias
complètement disparu de serre alors j'ai
une petite idée de comment on bosse pas
ce que je veux dire regardez très qui
sont communs à toute la profession sur
des trucs
ben voilà le droit de réponse heures
mais les sources je fais enfin bon bref
qualité des méthodes ce qui est
applicable partout mais pas de ce soir
radio ou n'importe où mais mais après
vraiment les contraintes spécifiques à
tel ou tel secteur et ses jeux les jeux
les covenants je les connais pas bien en
fait je connaissais je connais les
miennes ok d'accord que ça va encore
plus plausible de recherche jusqu'au
delà c'est vrai mais c'est passé
commande à la recherche c'est très
difficile de parler à quelqu'un qui ait
pas de temps de m la diplomate
ouais enfin une maturité en reste entre
mathématiciens par exemple et enfin ce
même plus que ça c'est une mathématicien
dénombre ne parle pas des mathématiciens
away ah ouais c'est vraiment il ya des
branches et des souffrants paris c'est
ça c'est pas du tout ne s'est pas une
histoire de pas vouloir qu'on ne
fréquente pas de ban n'a en fait c'est
tout simplement n'est pas dans les mêmes
médias on n'est pas dans les mêmes
pièges manenti ici un saut si un soir tu
vas avoir une soirée à reporters sans
frontières par exemple et badila tu vas
rencontrer des gens évidemment de
différents médias machin mais c'est pas
ça devrait pas grand chose il ya des
parias pas là il n'ya pas d'opportunité
naturel de rencontres ça
voilà à part peut-être quelques trucs je
pâlis clients de reporters sans
frontières ça serait peut-être web
mathématiques sans frontières a choisi
entre autres l'éducation des matches
comme ça où tout d'un coup à va y avoir
des gens ici des différences se ouais
mais sinon effectivement ça se mélange
peu mais pas par et puis aussi les
journalistes probablement dans la
recharge aussi mais c'est des gens ce qu
en moi j'ai une association j'ai pas une
association c'est une association qui a
été je suis président d'une association
qui a été monté par un certain nombre de
journalistes qui s'appelle fait cov et
pour les corps on va dans les combats
dans l'est notamment dans les classes et
auprès de jeunes enfants après tout
public en fait on allait les aider à
naviguer dans cet océan de fait que muse
et et tout ça pour dire qu'en fait on
pour calais pour réussir à avoir deux
journalistes font se lever très tôt et
il faut les cas les deux mois à l'avancé
donc c'est aussi que ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est aussi des gens qui ont
des vies pas possible souvent et c'est
donc c'est encore plus rare encore plus
compliqué si tu veux la rencontre inter
mieux le croiser au vote par hasard dans
un couloir que c'est plus probable que
les cavs a rendez vous à la base mais du
coup c'est une question de temps avant
que d'oublier mais qu'est ce qui peut
être amélioré
il ya tellement de choses qui peuvent
être alors faut savoir de quoi on parle
en fait c'est ça le truc
qu'est ce qui peut être amélioré dans
quoi parce que moi encore une fois je
connais le journalisme qui n'est pas le
la télé hier de manière générique qui
c'est à dire que moi par exemple ce qui
se passe en plateau avait fait mais je
n'ai aucune idée de qui le enfin je sais
pas mon métier en fait c'est noël moi
mon métier c'est pour ça que souvent
d'ailleurs j'ai des échanges
intéressants notamment avec les jeunes
et tous quand il me parle de bfm oui il
ya défectueuses sur bfm cet accord est
souvent quand tu creuses
parce que moi je dis mes attentes quelle
fille claudia sur bfm à mon avis tu n'es
pas d'accord avec la ligne éditoriale
il ya une question de ligne éditoriale
c'est à dire que t'es pas d'accord avec
le fait que sa part que deux flics
globalement sans folie des jeux
moi je regarde jamais déjà obligé de
regarder d'accord la première chose que
je dis à tout le monde parce que c'est
là dessus 2 si tu regardes tes pas avec
corps n'était pas d'accord a priori
c'est pas tellement d'effets que nous
c'est là c'est le l'angle en fait c'est
la ligne éditoriale qui est prise mais à
chaque fois et demi le taux de fait que
nous chez bfm je pense qu'il est je sais
pas peut-être de 0,01 pour cent alors là
ils sont tous là quoi
mais n'importe quoi pas plus tard
qu'hier machin et quand tu creuses en
fait ils les trucs avec lesquels ils
sont pas d'accord cd souvent quand c'est
des faits que news que des fois c'est
justice et de paix sont pas d'accord de
base c'est tout mais le truc est bref
mais quand c'est l'effet que nude entre
guillemets c'est des trucs qui ont été
balancés en plateau tu vois hélas il est
là je me retrouve à dire d'accord mais
tu sais que c'est pas la même chose en
fait c'est vrai que moi depuis tout à
l'heure je quand je dis qu'ils aient ya
0,001
peut-être le fait que nous avait fait
mais en fait je parle des gens qui vont
sur le terrain à bfm déjà des
producteurs d'infos en fait donc
et toi et toi tu me parle finalement de
gens en plateau mais si tu veux 7,7
on parle de différents pas en fin de
je ne peux pas parler enfin comment dire
c'est pas assez pas ne s'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout la même chose en fait
des gens qui ont aidé les les neuf à
l'aller les petits producteurs d'infos
dont je fais partie souvent ils sont
confondus avec avec les gros c'est comme
si d'ailleurs je faisais le parallèle un
peu dans une courbe dernièrement c'est
un peu comme si l'on prenait j'ai pas le
produit petits producteurs de carottes
ou de lait et qu'on allait les voir en
disant ouais l'acte est la dernière fois
ils ont p si vous êtes dès que nous à
des coups mais est longue et il a pas de
rapport avec ça il essaye de produire
son petit l'aise tu veux ait fait ce
qu'il peut tu vois web a des fois que
peut-être terrain taiclet sur un budget
de 30 ans enfin j'en sais rien c'est toi
et donc c'est très bizarre
en tant que journaliste d'accueillir ce
genre de deux remarques parce que je
n'ai pas on parle pas du tout de la même
chose en fait les gens en fait globalise
un espèce de truc qui est genre la télé
ces gens roulent les médias ou je sais
pas quoi messieurs à l'intérieur c'est
tellement complexe bell d'ailleurs comme
dans n'importe quelle entreprise ta ceux
qui font des stages ceux qui font l
autre ceux qui font tel autre machin
malheureusement les plus visibles
souvent à la télé c'est pas forcément
[Musique]
pas toujours c'est pas forcément
voilà ce qu'ils font là le travail le
plus rigoureux la terre mais comme c'est
ce qu'on voit le cul ça te retrouves
dessus france est très complet mais
qu'est-ce qui aurait amélioré
donc dans le doute dans le journalisme
je pense qu'en fait il n'y a pas grand
chose à améliorer si ce n'est qu' il
faut donner les moyens aux gens en fait
de travailler bien parce que je pense
que l' envie de l est là les
journalistes qui pleure parce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez de temps tous les jours
enfin j'exagère pas tous les jours mais
je gens voient passer partout ce donc et
je pense qu'il faut simplement trouver
un moyen et je sais pas quel et serait
ce moyen mais de faire en sorte que ces
gens là puissent vivre en fait
normalement de lors de l'heure de leur
métier quoi voilà donc ça c'est fort
journalistes et après pour les médias
traditionnels il ya un sacré paquet de
trucs à améliorer enfin en tout cas moi
qui moi me dérange
justement surtout ses polémistes enfin
je crois que j'ai pas la seule laure là
c'est presque en tant que citoyenne
aussi que je fais tous les toutes les
toutes les dérapages incontrôlés au
contrôle et où un contrôle et je sais
pas en plateau
c'est n'importe quoi enfin comment on
peut laisser passer ce genre de deux
choses le fait de le fait de deux
montées en épingle aussi des trucs tu
veux pas possible enfin j'ai pas de cas
concrets l'aqim bien mais
des fois il ya un emballement médiatique
sur un sujet qui va faire genre dix
jours quoi alors que mais c'est pas du
tout représente j'ai dit je t'aime bien
qu'ils s'appellent médiapolis cette
europe 1 c'est olivier duhamel tous les
week-ends et moi qui ai souvent pas trop
le temps de s'écouter comme ça d'être à
jour en permanence sur là dessus ça me
ça me fait vachement bien d'écouter
cette émission et lui il est hyper
critique aussi envers le système
médiatique et cetera tel qu'il
fonctionne et la dernière fois il
parlait des miss communautaire il ya eu
tout un débat sur les listes
communautaire parce qu'il ya eu quelque
part en france un petit une petite
bourgade dans quel ya une liste
communautaire en fête musulmane c'est
que c'est en fait c'est ce qu'on veut
dire ont été arrêtés et puis lui disais
mais ce truc là c'est il ya des genres
60 personnes qui l'ont soutenu je sais
plus fort voir exactement les si tu veux
si tu roules exemple intéressant il faut
que je réécoute de seconde pour pallier
à m'excuser parce que je devrais
vraiment pas dire des sites allemands
mais en gros ils disaient mais ça on a
monté en épingle le gall enfin un truc
et ça représentait 60 personnes qui vont
voter pour une liste communautaire dans
une petite bourgade et c'est un élément
m'a fait la semaine là dessus avec les
gars a invité en plateau à bfm donc
quelque part
on leur met les propulse en avant aussi
ces gens-là remet donc enfin des trucs
tu veux et c'est très critique en fait
sur scène médiatique et très souvent
quand j'écoute qui avril à raison il a
raison olivier g je connaissais pas
avant c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit a
expliqué coûté que c'est vraiment très
bien c'est sur le lien entre médias et
politique et ça c'est passionnant mais
donc voilà le fait de monter en épingle
des choses qui n'ont qui n'ont en fait
en fait moi tout ce qui ne prend pas de
recul ça me gêne ouais donc dans
l'immédiat temps pour un paquet de
choses qui malheureusement prennent pas
de recul les lire il m'a un paquet qu'il
le faut malheureusement c'est pas les
plus vues des trucs que voilà les
grosses enquêtes etc puis à prendre du
temps du coup ça prend de l'argent et
c'est que ça met tout ce qui est web
pour les polémiques à deux francs là à
deux euros sont les sur des plateaux
stigmatisant plus avec tout ça vient
mais vachement de stigmatisation de
telle ou telle catégorie de personnes et
six ans je sais pas je sais pas quel est
le rôle exact du csa par exemple enfin
je juge appareils soient jamais creusé
ça à fond mais souvent je m'interroge en
fait non parce que quand je vois ce que
je vois et qu'en pense qu'on pense que
je dis mais en fait donc là ça passe ça
ouais d'accord
dont acte non mais si je veux dire c'est
c'est c'est eh ça ce sont des journées
sont en colère contre ça en fait un nom
et j'ai des filles de watts a fait des
machins on n'en peut plus peut être
parce que ça nous revient aussi dessus
tu vois et donc il est aussi urgent de
faire la part des choses et quelque part
ma chaîne j'espère aide aussi un peu à
ça c'est à dire que voilà ce que c'est
que entre guillemets le journalisme
quand on essaye de le faire en tout cas
en tout cas comme moi j'aime le faire et
c est je crois j'espère que ça participe
un petit peu a justement la
distanciation de ça c'est du journalisme
moi ma chaîne à wade fait qu'elle n'a
pas de rapport avec pascal praud qui va
raconter n'importe quoi sur le tu vois
c'est pas pareil en fait on
n'a pas faim juge il ya zéro rapport je
pense que j'ai autant de rapports avec
pascal praud que toi par exemple
absolument on va me sortir régulièrement
quand je fais les courses c'est toi non
moi je sais pas je pense pas qu'on peut
effectivement l emporte cadereau
qu'est-ce que tu fais comme ça m'est
donc écoute voilà qu'est ce qui aurait
d'autres améliorer c'est pas genre
régulièrement je note des choses à
améliorer pour les jeunes réfléchissent
mais aussi aussi dans les débats rappaz
totaux des bâtons de mieux là dans les
débats encore souvent il ya des facteurs
de temps en temps et tout mais enfin
encore trop souvent il ya des conneries
qui ne qui part mais je veux dire qui ce
qu'on laisse passer à des heures de
grande écoute en plus enfin moi je j'ai
alors on va te dire oui mais bon des
gens sont en direct et tout ça c'est
très compliqué et puis nous on n'a pas
de 2,2 de vérifier en direct mais j'ai
la sensation que tous les moyens sont
pas exploré non plus tu veux parce que
parce qu'en fait il ya une
responsabilité parce qu'à partir du
moment où tu laisses passer comme ça des
gens qui se servent de ton plateau télé
radio pour l'heure pour l'heure comme
c'est de la com en fait hein alors là je
prends des politiques évidemment mais
alors pas tous pareils je veux pas
mettre dans le même sac tous les
politiques un avis fondé de leurs supers
nanas un bon bref
mais en tout cas
il y en a un certain nombre qui se
servent de ton voilà je sais pas moi la
matière de france inter ou de n'importe
quelle radio comme ça avant comme comme
un espace qu'un petit puta quand tu vois
j'exagère un peu mais voilà de com mais
s'il n'y a pas de minimum qui est fait
pour les responsabiliser sur ce qui est
dit du coup quelle est la différence
avec ce mec là qui se trouvait sur sa
chaîne youtube en racontant n'importe
quoi alors je dis pas ça je veux pas que
ça soit pris comme les journalistes font
pas leur boulot après il ya petit audel
va nous faire des leçons et c'est parce
que je sais que c'est dur
j'imagine que c'est dur on jamais arrivé
comme ça en direct en politique comme la
salle annexe terme et c'est c'est enfin
il faut il faut il faut s'interroger
là-dessus et c'est bien de questionner
sur sûr enfin voilà de chercher entre
guillemets un peu bas la petite bête
décide à l'herbe fondeurs et oumé mais
si c'est pour laisser passer des
énormités à côté ça c'est pas possible
et là je pense en fait directement un
cas qui m'a ulcéré qui est philippe de
villiers qui s'est pointé sur le sur le
plateau de france inter et qui ressortit
n'importe quoi sur l'union européenne
nazila j'avais fait une vidéo sur le nir
rosen l'asie c'est fou de c'est fou
quand il n'y a plus de limites l'union
hôtel nazis d'accord et enfin d'origine
bon bref ceux qui s'intéressent
regardant la vidéo et est en fait au
câble ou quoi la semaine d'après fille
de villiers qui sur le plateau de france
inter ressort jeu
les principaux arguments débiles en fait
de ce truc là il a ça à mes qui le
contredit par quoi ça ça fait mal quoi
tu vois ce que tu dis un concert que
ducros il se décarcasse the shop et
j'entends que peut-être qu'elle n'a pas
le temps de 20 que voilà c'est une
question de temps de préparation de
match armée mais mince quoi enfin je
sais pas puis je me dis moi j'ai regardé
ce cas là mais peut-être que si je
regardais de près tous les jours et tout
ça on arrivera à des chiffres énormes en
fait d'énormités 2
moi je les bus scolaires parce que
c'était un truc qui me concernait
directement et ça m'a tué mais donc
donc il ya des gars d il ya des choses à
trouver des dispositifs mais qui s'en
foutait un peu coûteux mais il faut et
je pense qu'il faut le faire pour pour
pour là aussi redonner un peu fort
expliqué que c'est un plateau de deux
journalistes c'est à dire que c'est pas
on vient pas ici raconter tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est elle être mis en
face de vos contradictions vous allez
être mais de manière plus sérieuse
encore et plus
comme le dira pas plus sérieuse mais
plus plus rigoureuse encore il y aura
jamais assez de rigueur en fait là
dessus donc il faut trouver il faut
trouver un il faut il faut trouver des
moyens parce que parce que je pense que
ça ça participe aussi au fait que du
coup les gens peuvent se dire finalement
des péquenots l'aurait sur les mais il y
en a sur les médias traditionnels c'est
quoi la différence avec ma chaîne
youtube jean-jacques 25 quoi tu vois
c'est aux peurs il faut il
il faut vraiment faire la différence
parce que les gens nous attendent là
dessus aussi quoi machine donc il ya ça
il ya j'ai pas après moi c'est décédé
après là je me prends à rêver hein parce
que j'ai un programme aussi je me suis
dit un jour si je suis présidente
obligatoire les coins de rue non non
mais je pense que ça donne mais des fois
je me prends à rêver en fait la société
idéale c'est j'ai besoin de ça parce que
sinon je crois que je dépérit trop et
des fois je me dis typiquement parce que
moi je suis quelqu'un qui tue quelqu'un
qui je suis capable de me désintéresser
très très très très très vite la
politique dès que je vois que ça part en
truck de marchands de tapis de fin enfin
les des bars en fête me blase tellement
sûr mais j'aime pas ça parce que c'est
pas normal de se désintéresser de la
politique et donc et et donc je me
retrouve un peu coincé dans ses dents
ces trucs là et je trouve qu'il ya
peut-être des moyens de faire justement
débattre des dés
des hommes politiques etc mais de
manière intelligente parce que ça puisse
pas partir dans des extrémismes pas
possible et c'est donc je sais pas je
n'en parlais tout à l'heure avant le
mais je suis toujours hyper preneuse de
toutes les pistes possibles et
imaginables qui pourrait permettre un
débat pareil c'est à dire avait pas
intelligent dans lesquelles les gens
devraient voilà enfin peuvent changer la
vie par exemple le so you can do et tu
as si tu es bien et j'étais pas
politique sommes pas bons il faudra
veiller à la télé
quelqu'un qui fin d'année je pense que
le problème des licornes et crédible
mais je pense que les gens ont besoin de
ça moi je
par exemple si j'étais politique jeu je
me mettrais je serai jamais vous étiez
d'accord mais je miserais vachement là
dessus sur le fait de dire à la
franchement je crois que je me suis
grâve planter c'est comme traduire lors
du france mais il faut le dire vous
allez moi les intérêts des crédits
finalement si tu le dis ça parce qu'il
faut il faut aussi savoir être honnête
avec soi-même on n'est pas toujours au
top
on en a parfois des jugements qui sont
en tout cas moi personnellement un homme
politique qui aurait qui tiendrait ce
discours là franchement chapeau près ça
que je trouverais ça c'est vraiment
c'est la raison pour laquelle chose que
ça s'est passé malheureusement
improbable balles et les hommes
politiques souvent un cd de combattre
d'autres hommes politiques dans leur
propre parti et du coup il faut qu'ils
aient l'adhésion de lors de leur groupe
et du couffo qui disent que leur groupe
temps c'est qu'ils le disent c'est pour
ça qu'il faut une toute nouvelle société
un nouvel homme réservé je pense tout à
nos entraînements
non mais oui non oui je suis d'accord ah
oui et donc dans ma société utopique la
page
en fait on
[Musique]
c'est sympa de candidater pour la
présidentielle mais sauf qu'au bout de
par exemple c'est pas ta un taux de fait
que nous en fait c'est à dire qu'en fait
tu démarres ta candidature longtemps je
vois sa campagne
c'est comme vous avez des points comme
dans tout jeu mario kart et l'attaquent
l'incitent à 15.6 news et dont cap à la
semaine d'après sur le plateau de machin
pas dit alors faut bien s'entendre pour
moi c'est nous c'est pas se planter sur
un chiffre et ses avants faut il faut
définir ce que c'est pour moi c'est des
trucs manipulateur en fait non je parle
mais au bout de dix ans a battu sortent
du game eux c'est fini merci au revoir
que plus candide été mais non mais je ne
sais pas quoi en fait mais pas que ça
enfin alors maintenant parce que je
pense que tu rigole parce que tu connais
le système actuel est que ça te paraît
totalement impossible qu'on va
s'embellir
mais dans une société qui est normal
c'est normal parce que c'est c1 c'est un
c'est comme un des règles du jeu en fait
parce que aussi ici ici il ya plus de
règle du jeu qu'avant il y en a pas
tellement d'arrêt de jeu c'est assez de
la poudre aux conneries quelque part
j'exagère mais qui qui qui peut s'est
vue qui peut rappeler la miss
politiquement et cbc et permanente à la
société idéale au chant au matin non je
ne sais pas d'accord on a tjrs si jamais
il ya un mathématicien qui canon son
prêt avec l'appoint des fausses mais il
fait il ya un peu une humiliation
quand vous prenez mathématicien passé à
[ __ ] a très mal de se dire j'ai prouvé
seraient en fait la preuve les choses
mais les cas et alors donc ce comptage
des points il existe en date ce qu'est
ce que je peux dire à bas donc il peut
exister donc tu vis des quidams ans je
pense qu'il peut espérer non c'est comme
je sais pas il ya bien d'autres règles
les règles de financement de la campagne
les règles ne touchent pas quoi il ya
toute une batterie de règles pour quand
est candidat mais ça c'est ça c'est une
sacrée règles à mettre en place ce que
je comprends même pas qu'elle est certes
à dire tu vends parce que
bah tout de suite le jeu devient un peu
plus compliqué ben oui mais c'est tout
en hauteur c'est tout l'art de tu vois
t'as pas le droit de faire prendre
n'importe quoi et de dire avec les
promesses c'est peut-être des fois je me
suis interrogé sur les promesses et c
est ce qu il faut
est-ce qu'il faut cesser le plus
compliqué mais en tout cas les maires
eux mais en tout cas l'effet que nous
pardi dire il faut le seul point le gros
problème de ça c'est de définir en fait
quel est le quel est le le point que tu
perds en faisant tu as fait knut ac tue
le père avec quel genre de faits mais
sinon franchement moi je trouve que
c'est simple à mettre en place il faut
fit équipe de debug
je sais pas quoi voilà ce qui est plus
chaque plateau télé machin et puis au
fil des semaines
à bas la marine le pen elle a perdu
trois avis cette semaine dealer c'est
rigolo tellement il ya un côté fun moi
ça ne doit pas faire ça mais à la presse
que tu reconnaîtras boulette
tu peux regagner des vies peut-être une
chance à ces jeunes que tu vois tu peux
gagner tu peux aller te regarde une
petite vie si tu dis ok c'est fait
amende honorable qui a patienté
tu vois il ya quelqu'un change d'avis
mais avec raison justifiée tazi je me
suis trompé à semaine dernière je pense
maintenant que c'est parfait bien ca
batna tu peux avoir des points positifs
on avait fait ça mais moi je pense qu'il
faut il faut tu vois après il est
annoncé comme quoi il est allemand cc
comptage de points au lieu dans la tête
des joueurs qui ont des spectateurs et
fin des programmes c'est qu'il a pas eu
dans la tête des gens qui explique la
terreur dit que c'est à dire ben pas
idéalement toit dans un débat à chaque
fois que quelqu'un sans quelqu'un il
sort quelque chose d'erroné passer un
petit peu bas tous les spectateurs de
dire a du coup lui doit y perdre des
points si ces spectacles point où le
citoyen ouais ouais
et si si il y avait un peu plus à ce que
des gros preuve aujourd'hui c'est que
dans ce genre de débat
auprès des spectateurs de celui qui
gagne des points il ya deux pas des
points parce qu'il a sorti parce qu'ils
y affine rhétorique truc il devrait pas
marquer des points comme celle qui
détient 20 théorie devrait oui mais
qu'est ce que tu proposes défaut par
rapport à ça mais c'est très compliqué
comme et basta tu peux pas empêcher
aprilia du grand orateur des prophètes
comme les chasseurs mais bon on est
mauvais quoi mais je dirais l'opérateur
il parle les gens votent pour lui quand
même temps lui aussi mais les mauvais
non mais je ne sais pas mais je ne sais
pas il ya sûrement je veux tu te rends
pas la première à réfléchir à ça il ya
plus d avance de trucs comme ça qui ont
été imaginés peut-être dans des d'autres
pays réfléchissent elsa j'en sais rien
mais je vois pas comment on peut s'en
sortir sans mettre en place un truc
comme ça qui est encore une fois ne
paraît un truc un peu basique finalement
c'est pas la fin
et puis ce serait marrant à la fin de la
campagne tu vois d'ailleurs ça
d'ailleurs réjoui s'ils le font déjà
certains de dire à la fin de la campagne
tiens tel candidat il en a sorti douze
la dernière semaine 12 comme rihanna la
semaine l'autre il en a fait trois
grosses qu'on va te dire tu es là tu
vois quand on fait un petit montage
comme ça et puis j'ai enfin j'en sais
rien mais il ya tout est une règle du
jeu en fait à avoir au niveau 2 c'est
toujours la même chose c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire une machine s'est
responsabilisé les gens sur ce qu'ils
disent
j'ai pas possible de prendre de balancer
des trucs et de prendre vos
responsabilités dessus et ça c'est trop
courant et c'est trop c'est trop
c'est très possible quoi et donc l'idée
c'est tu fais campagne c'est très bien
on est très heureux pour toi mais c'est
pas la fête
c'est pas la fête de la parole tu te
vois pas je ne savais pas la fête
ou alors c'est nous alors la fête c'est
bâtir à la mer chez toi parce qu'en fait
tu vas juste sortir du circuit 4 on doit
leur donner du grade de confiance aussi
les citoyens envers la politique ça tu
vois ouais c'était n'importe quoi
des fois ça part tellement dans tous les
sens et tout si c'est quelque part tu
sais qu' il ya des garde-fous en termes
de entre guillemets de manipulation fin
web attendait mais enfin voila c is it à
ces règles là tu peux a déjà avoir un
peu plus confiance dans le process tu
vois pas je sais pas je pense
bon après tout ça c'est sans parler de
toutes les campagnes d'intox sur les
réseaux sociaux les facebook les machins
me sens comme un truc mais en tout cas
on dans les prises de parole des
politiques
ça me parait ouais j'ai un truc au début
des bulles à qui tu fais comment moi un
de mes grands sujets où il va revenir à
7 les systèmes de recommandation d'ubs
et finalement il ya une timide raté ses
grandes entre ce que fait cette ia et la
programmation sur les plateaux télé
c'est à dire que je pense que dans les
deux cas ce qui est maximisée c'est pas
forcément la qualité d'information ce
qu'une de vue qui va être fait ah oui
oui bah oui et que du coup les
informations qui sont plus recommandé
vidéo qu'est ce qu'on ai pas vus tuer
vous allez les individus les plus mis en
avant par les plateaux télé ou plutôt
être ce qui manque la lourde
ouais dans le radical est en fait la
même dans la compense du cou à des gens
qui font ça ça c'est comme le youtuber
qui n'importe quoi mais s'il fait plein
de vue by youtube en gros va lui donner
point de vue du centenaire a laissé
comme si on youtube l'encouragé à
continuer quoi mbc de la mafia et de la
même façon sur les plateaux télé si on
l'invité invite des gens qui disent mais
c'est aussi sévère c'est pour ça que je
parle c'est ça tu vois ou deux
tu devrais enfin je suis trop ignorants
sur la question donc je veux vraiment
pas dire de bêtises quoi mais le comment
ça se fait enfin quels sont les je pense
qu'il faut renforcer les sanctions à
l'encontre des médias qu'il est ce qu'il
est et tel énergumène dire n'importe
quoi sur leur plateau là non plus c'est
pas la fête en fête
mais c'est pas très vendeur comme
programme politique c'est pas la fête
avec aude se sera pas à la fête non mais
je pense d'ailleurs dans le complotisme
et tout ça j'en discutais enfin avec un
journaliste s'appelle paul moreira qu'un
voile à reporter quelqu'un couvert nous
parle de conflit et c'était entre autres
choses et il lui disait et je pense
qu'il n'a pas tout à fait ton église et
mais en fait les les médias fameux
médias traditionnels etc
ils ont vachement fait le lit de toutes
les compétitions aussi en parce que
parce que une époque pas si lointaine
est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si on est beaucoup mais en tout cas
pendant très longtemps on a laissé
couler comme sale et thierry meyssan les
machins et truc c'est pas enfin tu vois
ce que ça fait de l'audience en fait et
[Musique]
effectivement c'est plus sexy que
d'avoir cette histoire qui va te
raconter qu'en fait c'est un qui va te
faire rentrer dans les subsides et par
moi je trouve ça sexy que certains qui
me fait rentrer mais j'suis pas sûr que
pour le public moyen ça le soit et donc
et donc et donc ça il faut arrêter en
fait top mais faut arrêter brutalement
il faut pas c'est toi qu'on a hâte et
les transforment en café de comptoir je
préfère aller au café ça va je l'avais
dit tout avec des dés puis ça va être
bien on va bien s'entendre sur un shot
un show de vodka et il veut même aidé
des fois le niveau il n'est pas plus
loin
tu vois donc c'est grave ça ouais mais
voilà mais je le jure je j'avoue que je
enfin je dis ça mais je ne regarde pas
non plus justement tellement ça m'a
écoeuré pour la période je regarde pas
beaucoup de débats à la télé direct
moi je veux vraiment regardé les infos
justement pour faire encore cette
différence moi je regarde les infos je
regarde les reportages sont faits par
les gens où je sais qu'ils sont comme
moi et je sais qu'ils ont la même enfin
je vois très bien comment ils y
travaillent
etc etc et jeu et j'ai confiance du coup
parce que je vois ce que je veux faire
j'ai plus confiance enfin en tout cas
que quand tout le reste c'est à dire
qu'ils font pas des bêtises et
potentiellement mais enfin et c'est là
que je sais c'est ça pour moi c'est là
que je m'informe mais c'est pas
tellement je suis plus informés en
regardant un gros docu sur tel ou tel ou
tel sujet que en regardant à deschamps
de débattre sur un plateau télé où il
n'y aura pas de facture qui ne forcément
pendant ça va être un peu tout le monde
est dans une espèce de poids sur les
postures surtout en avait marre et
postures je suis l'accueil des hôtes et
juste sur ne sais plus
alors je suis journaliste particulière
en cela que je ne suis pas au fait en
permanence de actu du jour etc etc
en fait je alors je m'en vante pas parce
que c'est pas évidemment je pense que
j'ai une grosse je pense que il ya
plusieurs raisons à ça un je pense que
pendant une grosse période j'ai fait
trop ça quand j'étais dans les chaînes
d'info etc
genre tu te lèves le matin il faut que
tu connaisses parker l'aktu t'arrive
c'était le fil afp donc c'est à dire que
tu as donc la france qui t'envoient en
fait l'agenda de la journée et c'est que
tulle un tel match il faut que tu etc et
c'est comme ça tout le temps et ça a un
côté amusant au début août à un peu le
menu quoi tous les jours tu as devenu un
moyen aujourd'hui on va parler de saraya
sarko qui fait que c'est sarko qui va
faire un d'accord auquel va s'exprimer
en direct et sénas parfait et mais je
pense qu'à la fin ça m'a écoeuré
peut-être oussama en fait j'aime pas
tellement l'actus je préfère l'info
méchant que ses patrouilles dans pareil
je sais pas si c'est le bon ton ferme
que j'ai que j'emploie mais après dans
ma tête c'est à peu près clair c'est à
dire que je trouve que quand tu écoutes
de l'info en continu tus l actu mais moi
je me sens pas plus grandi entre
guillemets intellectuellement en termes
d'informations sur le monde
j'ai je sais tu vois je ne sais pas si
c'est or c'est ça que je cherche donc
donc en fait
bah je prends le risque de pas être au
fait des derniers trucs qui s'est passé
il ya deux jours etc
mais en revanche je vais me poser de
trois fois par mois devant un gros doc
qui va m'expliquer il était dans les
aboutissants d'un tel ou tel sujet et
et je vais me sentir en fait plus plus
entre guillemets intelligent tout cas
moins bête à la fin parce que des fois
il sera coté à ce moment aussi les lun
et c'est bon j'ai des gens sur twitter
qui me disent non et qui disait un
essaim voies de fait qu'un petit réagit
pas rapidement
et puis alors là parce que c'est le coin
où est ce que c'est pour l'heure à
l'incident à rennes etc
mais c'est quoi j'en sais rien en fait
tout ce que je sais c'est que si tu
cherches à avoir la vérité au bout d'une
heure où l'incident il s'est produit un
gars tu étais mal barré et donc en
général quand il ya surtout des coûts
d'actifs comme ça des trucs chômage un
cas unique explose au j'en sais rien
encore plus que d'habitude je me fais
comme la tortue une carapace
je ne veux pas voir mon fils twitter et
je refais surface dix jours plus tard et
là je sais qu'il ya tous les bons
papiers qui sont sortis parce que comme
je connais enfin je sais que les
journalistes auront du coup ceux qui
sortent à ce moment là les papiers
auront vraiment une pompe d'injection
sujet et donc je regarde à ce moment là
mais je hais je pense c'est pas pour
dire que j'ai une je sais pas si c'était
génial etc
mais je pense qu'on sera peut-être tout
simplement plus serein dans notre tête
si on consommait l'info l'info comme ça
enfin tout cas moi j'ai un truc
épidermique qui fait que dès que ça
s'emballe jeu qu'à ce jeu même dans la
foule je suis assez agoraphobe si
j'avais par contre ya trop de gens moi
je suis jamais aussi bien que chez moi
avec un petit et un bouquin tu vois et
donc dès que ça prend comme ça avec eux
ça bourdonne quand je vois qu'ils soient
autonomes et se décolle pas par contre
il faut absolument que tu es tu
donc en fait enfin voila je du coup je
ne suis pas l'actualité au jour le jour
ce pareil pour tout te dire ce matin
madame je ne sais pas qu'est ce qui se
passe là tout de suite c'était quoi là
tu sais pas j'ai entendu un truc sur
[Musique]
l'huile de palme c'est comme ça que
j'attends la ville de palm hp excessif
et la fac vous dépanne d'ailleurs
quelque chose mais non c'est tout mais
je mets mes cessé de faits troublants
c'était encore je vais là c'est quand je
des sciences po ouais t'as toujours le
tronçon je sais pas quoi qu'il se pointe
et qui fait au repas de famille et qui
dit à aude c'est quoi le président du
sénat c'est là bas j'en sais trop rien
fait a basé sa chance pour la magicienne
d'accord bas la relève voir la relève
toi et ce genre de romain quand tu es
journées c'est pareil donc en fait j'ai
juste switcher de c'est quelqu'un qui va
sortir un truc qui s'est passé hier
et si t'es pas au courant tu vas passer
pour la pire journalistes du monde quoi
suva genre havas bravo et bamba était
quoi je suis une journée de merde alors
tant pis tu vois appelle moi comme ça
mais moi j'ai juste envie je n'aime pas
être dans la sueur dans la consommation
frénétique de l'info je n'arrive pas à
m'en fait lui aussi une question de
temps oui mais ce truc similaire avec
tes matin alors que la pression qui va
payer quoi tu veux pas faire le calcul
est intervenue lors la tradition je sais
pas personne je suis mathématicien je
suis pas que le kilo triste ouais bah
voilà mais c'est un point de vue c'est
ce que tu es ce que 20 il ya un pilleur
en fait monsieur nombreuses questions
diable par la queue à oisy timbre
hygiène mentale histoire fait c'est
aussi mon cas
cros a fait vous avez cinq ans que je
cherche à ne jamais connaître
l'actualité à sa fin c'est quelque chose
de tout ce que tu cherches là quand même
je fais un effort conscient et pourquoi
il passe pas ce que je fais c'est en
gros une attention limitée
oui oui c'est ça c'est le montant limité
et il ya des sujets qui sont plus
importantes que l'actualité je pense
d'accord d'accord mais quand t'es pas
journaliste tellement gênant et quand tu
es journaliste il est cette injonction
était censé être au courant de tout en
société voilà c'est ça tu es censé
savoir faire une addition à mais bon si
tu as besoin de savoir c'est bien je
trouve
moi je trouve que c'est bien en fait on
se perd complètement avec ses pieds
alors moi je dis pas au moindre truc qui
se passeront bien boire at what the fake
que fait la police quand tu vois bosser
fait qu'elle était contraire à la il
sera aidé ont sorti un bien beau linge
pas quoi à quoi est fait et puis quand
tu réagis pas ces genres ah bah ça ça
veut dire déjà ils pensent qu'ils
tombent bouche etc n'y a pas de réponse
et alors là elle est là elle répond pas
on l'a fait ban en ga en fait en train
de faire mes courses et quoi j'ai eu ma
fille à nourrir j'ai éventuellement de
doc intéressant à regarder ce soir
c'est un bouquin donc j'ai en fait je
vais pas répondre à ta question sur et
c'est pas parce que je te méprise ou je
sais pas quoi c'est juste que et comme
tu dis attention limitée
je me faut que je me me focaliser sur
les trucs importants quoi j'ai en fait
la page sur mon dieu que c'est vrai
qu'on est trop sursaturé de
l'information mais je trouve que ça
enfin moi je leur ressemble
j'ai l'impression que je ressens
vraiment cette espèce de bouillie dans
mon cerveau si je regarde par exemple 30
minutes d'affilée et un truc d'info en
continu ouais bah c'est bon mais c'est
vrai sur cet anneau jean parce qu'elle
est dans mon coeur qu'un venir me voir
qu'on parle de l'infobésité caravane tu
peux dire ouais bah voilà messieurs en
s'amusant
un peu abruti par comme j'imagine site
avait quelqu'un qui te déblatérait comme
ça des milliards de trucs quand pas de
rapport c'était top
mais mais mais mais c'est le problème
s'est passé c'est une étude que j'ai
passé là dessus mais en gros ça a des
conséquences aussi un peu de lait face
tu as donc par exemple à ce que t'en
prendre à compter sur toi expérience à
toi c'est à dire qu' il ya des gens du
coup qu'il s'intéresse plus du tout l
actu voilà où peut-être il ya cinq ou
dix ans ils s'intéressaient elle
compatit on a tellement trop et puis
c'est tellement ça part dans tous les
sens et les gens c# à fabrègues a
peut-être espèce de big 22 bazar pas
possible quoi qui fait que les gens
puissent à des gens dont je suis un peu
tu vois a évidemment j'essaie de lui fin
je me tiens au courant minimum mais
voilà mais c'est je trouve que c'est
quelque part cette pub pour une société
en tout cas su réfléchissez pas bon non
plus bien des gens qui se désintéresse
du lac tu vois dans prête on n'a pas
intéressé à toutes les 91 pour son nom
alors ça je vais d'accord de façon
personne personne ne s'intéresse de fils
à toutes les actus cieux mais j'avais
pas ce que je dis c'est parce que je
crois que j'avais vu break je regarde
mais il me semble que c'était une espèce
de tendance qu'avait été dégagés dans la
société de plus en plus de gens qui ne
veulent plus rien savoir
genre du monde tu vois tellement en fait
un espèce de con tre cool tu veux de ces
espèces d'infobésité et jean du coup
qu'ils disent c'est quoi moi ciao je
vais juste un rosé mais planté il ya
c'est très bien je veux dire mais tu
vois ce que te dire ça pose aussi
question
parce que ouais je je je je sais pas il
ya un équilibre à trouver mais il n'est
pas facile parce que maintenant c'est à
chacun de gérer son équilibre de
quelconques comment tu consommes l'info
avant on n'avait pas tellement on
n'essaie pas tellement le choix ou tu
vois que tu avais le jt du 20h ou je
sais pas quoi mais là maintenant
tellement tout le monde est sursaturé tu
es obligé de trouver un gestion dans
fait de sa et mais je trouve que je
trouve que c'est bien effectivement
d'essayer de prendre de la distance au
maximum parce que sinon tu fais pour un
cadre et puis l'indignation pousser tous
les jours 9 indignation je ne peux pas
tenir
c'est aussi un tu te dire des sections
importantes du livre papa m'a dit je ne
peux pas vous dire comme ça de ma chaise
c'est une fender fois par jour charest
pas une animation sont pas du tout
efficace c'est souvent rigolo rend plus
en plus là et ça ça pose comme question
donc mais je pense qu'il ya aussi ce qui
joue beaucoup à mon avis c'est le quand
on est sur des réseaux sociaux même si
moi je pense que ce sont des fois plus
associée aux cas sociaux
il ya aussi un peu bas la posture tu
sais ouais parce que mon ours le 11 mai
indigné par tu vas te dire ça voudront
montre qu' on est à on trouve qu'on
n'est pas d'accord avec on montre que
messi personne te regardais je pense que
tu en aurais rien à [ __ ] non non tu
vois et donc ça joue vachement ça va si
tu vois il c'est pour ça que j'avais
adoré avait un dernier petit speech
d'obama l'appeler partagez vous le
disais
en gros ils disaient mais c'est pas
les gens il pense que quelque part il
n'est plus comme il le disait mais en
gros les gens ce sont l'association
entre une méta gier et c'est à peu de
frais en disant à lui tu lui s'est
planté il a fait ça et c'est nul de
cette politique et puis alors lui a
encore plus nuls et fismes h1ni mais si
la seule chose que tu fais c'est jeter
pierres monde ah c'est pas ça le
l'activité je pense que le fait qu' on
est justement vu sociaux ça joue
vachement ouais on allie c'est ce même
personne là je suis pas sûr que tout
seul sans que personne ne le voit il
serait indigne est à ce point de suture
ouais et ses doigts dans les ventes par
deux du cadre de l'économie la tension
peu de faire attention à limiter tous ne
sont pas prêts attention les méga
youtube to you tube heures et tout le
monde veut notre attention
et du coup les contenus qui qui ont
marché le mieux c'est ce qu'ils vont
facilement avoir beaucoup d'attention
que et l'indignation c'est jackpot quoi
c'est pas mais les gens ils arrivent à
tenir tout ça on tend à houeillès mais
je pense que c'est un sentiment qui est
ultra addictif chez beaucoup de gens
classés
tu te sens un peu les études l'assuré
est ce que tu es assez unanimes c'est ce
que tu peux être donc la lettre la
colère en particulier payer une étude
notamment la chitine que la colère se
propage beaucoup plus vite ils partent
ils on partage beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus les contenus qui celui-ci
de colère que les autres ouais mais
après c'est des femmes
je dis que la nation est devenu très
très très courte
bah oui les puis le jugement tu sais moi
j'ai du mal avec ça le jugerait c'est
vrai on sait des trucs le jugement
permanent des gens mais regardez vous
même sérieusement quoi le et moi même je
le dis pour moi aussi quoi des fois j'ai
envie de
mais ce gars là est en fait je suis pas
dans ses baskets c'est quoi je sais pas
peut-être que yanis a presque en fait le
truc a été sortie de son contexte pour
ça peut-être que ce gars là il a eu
cette histoire là dans sa vie qui est
comme je pense à du coup je me retiens
de faire le tweet qui va dire ça tu vois
c'est que et sinon les gens ils sont là
et c'est un je ne sais pas mais c'est
les bras production c'est la production
de laquelle je fais what the fuck c'est
une amie qui s'appelle susanna de deux
rage de ragots sénat demande franco
allemande est elle il ya une remise de
zebra que j'aime bien ces genres ne juge
aucun homme avant d'avoir marché avec
ses mocassins durant cette ligne c'est
aux bernois
c'est vraiment la démocratie on les a
bernés il a deux vocations les
amérindiens
non mais voilà bon bref juste pour dire
qu'on perd un peu la boule quoi d'accord
donc ça m'inquiète des fois je peux pas
un peu plus de tâches et de comment ça
se passe bah écoute
[Musique]
ma chaîne donc je suis content d'avoir
fait ça oui c'est un je retourne sur ce
que je voulais dire ah ça y est il y
avait ensuite terminé à temps faut pas
que je perde mais le oui là où je suis
super contente en fait c'est carrie
cette chaîne jeu déjà bas ça c'est hyper
riches d'enseignement parce que ça n'a
rien à voir mais de rien de faire du
journalisme un peu planqué entre
guillemets ok donc la plus plantée sur
youtube c'est un peu planqué à la télé
et de s'exposer directement sur youtube
donc j'ai vraiment de meilleurs
renseignements par rapport à ça c'est
vachement intéressante des fois c'est
pour le bien des façons pour le pire et
pour le meilleur des mondes mais c'est
vachement mais c'est quand même
vachement intéressant et puis surtout
mais tu vois rien que le fait qu'on est
en train de parler si j'avais continué
mais mes petits reportages lâchera en
train de bosser sur je sais pas moi un
scandale je sais pas à quoi ou chèque
déjeuner ben ça pas en train de parler
et j'aurais pas enfin en fait ce que je
veux dire c'est que le fait d'être sur
youtube c'est que ça m'a ouvert aussi
lâchement les sorties était de me parler
c'est ça le d'ores et déjà réfléchir
sans mon travail sur le journalisme ça
souvent pas le temps ça c'est comme si
tu demandais attend boulanger est alors
le secteur de landry en france comment
est ce que vous pensez
si le gars il a pas le temps enfin il en
fait il fait son pain juste doigts et
moi je faisais mon pain pendant
longtemps et est là en fait le fait
d'être en prise directe avec les gens et
c'est d'avoir des retours des critiques
j'adore vraiment j'encourage les gens à
le faire le maximum de critiques parce
que c'est c'est vraiment ça qui me fait
réfléchir au maximum et ses bas ça me
fait réfléchir au maximum que j'ai ce
que j'aurais pas en fait dans un dans en
faisant mon travail en attaque mais de
manière un peu traditionnelle etc et est
aussi ça m'a ouvert
tu vois par exemple cette histoire de
billets cognitif messieurs je n'avais
jamais entendu parler avant de vraiment
et d'ailleurs les journalisme légende
liste des journalistes
je pense j'essaye de d'impulser c'est un
peu dans l'association donc fait neuf
ans que je préside etc
j'essaie d'organiser des petites des
petits rendez vous avec des gens en
europe travaillent dans les
neurosciences et c'est pour faire
gamberger un peu là dessus parce que sur
les scientifiques les journalistes il
toutes ces histoires de biais cognitifs
etc mais personne nous l'apprendre nulle
part et personne ne sait et personne ne
voit ses propres billets puisque dans
tous les reportages mais comme mais
comme dans toute la vie tu veux il ya
forcément des petits biais des plats
site a commencé à raconter dans ton
histoire alors a pas la même tête si tu
commences à la raconter avec l'histoire
de l'assassin ou avec les soeurs de la
victime
c'est tout bête le gel elle-même et y
aura pas de fake news n'y aura pas deux
mais tu veux et qu'est ce qui fait que
tu as envie de recommencer que
l'assassin plutôt qu'avec la victime
passait parce que je sais pas feinte et
câblées d'une manière qui fait que tu
trouves que enfin juste réfléchir en
fait assez assez autre biais c'est
quelque chose que je pense que j'aurais
peut-être jamais fait si je n'avais pas
été sur youtube parce que ça m'a parce
qu'un des premiers petits fans entre
n'est pas c'est pas fameux mais une des
premières personnes qui m'a un peu suivi
soutenu c'est effrayant christophe
d'hygiène mentale donc j'ai découvert
hygiène mentale sur un monde parallèle
j'ai des faits quator aussi je trouve
vachement bien tu vois voilà que j'ai
croisés de trois fois et je trouve ça ça
voilà ça va ça m'a vachement ouvert
l'esprit toi par exemple ce que tu fais
tu vois où même ça mais tu sais que tu
vas fait découvrir aussi julia guerre
fameuse chercheuse en mai la vie quoi
qui a enfin qui qui qui qui fait
réfléchir de manière totalement folle
sur la façon dont on et clichy etc etc
mayrhuber pertinentes et enfin c'est
juste génial tout ça mais je pense que
je l'aurais jamais fait mais si je leur
ai jamais eues j'aurais jamais eu cette
espèce de
plus mais je serais passé à la coupe et
de tellement de choses j'ai pareil il ya
quelques jours j'étais à gérer je suis
allé à une soirée de kasma qui est qu'il
l'association de d'un mec formidable
s'appelle albert un bouquet hiver et qui
est pareil barre des 2 foyers multi
titre tu sais mais en gros neurosciences
neuroscientifique biais cognitif tout ça
voilà les zones denses et et c'était
formidable parce que ben parce que y
racontait enfin en gros il organise un
débat et puis essaye de voir tout ce qui
fait que ce débat déconner quelque part
que les arbres on était pas valable et
terex et ça me fait vachement réfléchir
sur le métier est sûre même la façon
dont moi je peux poser mes questions
interviews etc
mais tout ça c'est notamment positif en
fait comme apport et je n'aurais jamais
eu si j'avais pas si j'étais pas aller
sur youtube je pense vraiment pas parce
que parce que comme la plupart des
journalistes belges créent entre 1
perdre mon boulot qui me prend déjà 7
ans et machins et ça ça va ça m'a je
suis plus ouvert en fait non mais c'est
sam ouvrage quand l'esprit parce que
j'ai l'impression que je suis en fait
c'est comme s'il y avait un peu trop à
trois pieds tu vois j'ai un pied dans va
évidemment dans le journalisme parce que
ça que je fais ma vie un autre pied côté
citoyen c'est-à-dire là qui va être son
canapé qui va gueuler sur le débat
public et à la télé sur le fait que
c'est juste pas possible et que d'un
anodin donc voilà donc ce regard
critique là aussi je les ai un troisième
temps je trouve dans ces tss je sais pas
comment l'appeler mais cette espèce de
deux mondes que je découvre totalement
qui est le monde de comprendre comment
ton cerveau marché pourquoi tu penses
comme ça et tu étais hyper applicables
au journalisme
enfin partout en fait et moi c'est
vachement wiseed enfin moi je suis trop
content je me sens libéré enrichissant
et je les aurais pas pensé que ça
m'amènerait
tu vois et des fois je réfléchis je me
dis mais ya peut-être des c'est vraiment
des pistes que j'ai j'aimerais bien je
sais pas mais j'aimerais bien à l'avenir
en tout cas d'une manière ou d'une autre
essayé d'insuffler un peu plus de ça
justement de ramener un peu plus de 2
toute cette connaissance finalement sur
donc biais cognitifs sur toutes les
télés voilà le feu ça doit avoir un
autre ça ça des noms scientifiques mais
seulement je les connais pas mais tu
vois le fait de monter un petit truc en
épingle un instant il ya plein de gens
qui ont bossé là dessus qu'ils
connaissent par coeur c'est diana etc
etc
j'aimerais vachement être un peu la
passerelle entre ces gens là également
du voyage
tu vas voir ça ce que je trouverais ça a
changé et je trouve que enfin voilà
c'est ça met un peu dans une position un
peu mais inédite et je trouve ça je
trouve ça génial parce que même les
chercheurs voilà t'y pas vers même type
toi je sais pas si on discutait beaucoup
avec les journalistes par exemple tu
vois moi par des chercheurs ce que gm
installé aucun chercheur de base c'est à
dire je vais l'appenzelloise je juge
nouveau avec deux galas de deux super
pointures des voix la neuroscience
psychologique c'est tu vois moi ça m'a
impressionné un peu tu vois moi je suis
juste content si tu as aimé
mais sujet mes trucs mais c'est c'est je
trouve ça génial en fait parce que ça
crée des passerelles en fait entre les
mondes qui tu vois qui en tout cas c'est
si si globalement on a envie de le
décider de trouver des manières muté
compter à la fois content et etc nous
mais pour notre propre nos propres web y
est je trouve pas d'autres mots en fins
impropres la façon dont notre cerveau
déconne etc
je trouve que il faut faire un peu
l'alliance entre ces deux mondes nature
et donc
et donc voilà je me nourris enfin la
statue dans une phase où j'essaye de
nourrir et nourrir le plein de trucs et
aussi un super bouquin celui d'albert
mme guilbert et l'état le terrible est
géniale de fabuleux chantier rendre du
ans artificielle euros histoire
bénéfique rendre l'intelligence
indiciels
justement bénéfique waouh ok justement
est là pour attirer l'attention des
mathématiciens usa hockey mais en tout
cas la richesse au québec top mais le
local de l'état vers mon calvaire il est
top c'est sûr ça s'appellera terre vous
détournez est votre livre aussi que je
trouve ce faire et un et l'homme pareil
il est formidable c'est gérald bronner
et d'ailleurs c'est son bouquin la
démocratie des crédules qui m'as tu vois
je l'avais je n'ai même pas de citer
tout à l'heure parce qu'en fait c'est
multifactoriel
le fait que j'ai créé ma chaîne mais ça
a été un déclic en fin d'année lire ce
bouquin s'appelle la démocratie des
crédules etc est absolument formidable
enfin ça parle des croyances en fait
pourquoi est ce que finalement on
devient presque plus croyants avec
internet tu vois alors que quelque part
on aurait pu penser totalement le
contraire donc c'est issa explore ça
mais de manière hyper brillante enfin
ses juges et un bouquin génial et j'ai
il en a fait un deuxième a une âme en
fait d'autres mais le deuxième que j'ai
lus en tout cas c'est l'échéance de
rationalité je viens juste de finir est
pareil ces espaces qui l'allumé violence
grave parce que c'est
c'est la mission su elle est chaude
c'est en fait ils l'étaient dans le
premier centre de déradicalisation qui
monte en france qui est malheureusement
ça a capoté pour des raisons x y
enfin bref ils ont fait cette tentative
d'avoir ce centre là et donc il s'est
retrouvé lui à devoir quelque part fin
ratée rips veut les cerveaux les plus
hauts perchés de france quand tu veux
mais dangereusement perchée des radis
des débats du mal qui suit est vachement
intéressant de voir comment quelles
techniques il a essayé d'utiliser tu
vois il ya un passage que j'aime
beaucoup ça me fait franchement
réfléchir un passage que j'aime beaucoup
qui est sûr le père noël en fait parce
que c'est compliqué tu as tu n'as pas de
pointer en disant ah c'est quoi votre
balade
c'est n'importe quoi il faut que tu
viens en dix ans d'ailleurs le but c'est
par ici
c'est juste par une des croyances c'est
en fait le but c'est de les aider à
prendre contrôle de leur mental parce
que quand il ya ce niveau-là de
radicalisation tout mon talent et laisse
tomber lytro est parti est en fait par
exemple il prend une il fait une petite
analogie avec le père noël et et j'ai
trouvé ça vachement heureux de faire un
passage
monsieur lire ta seule voix alors en
fait y'a pas je crois qu'il ya pas un
passage particulièrement du fait que je
vais jésus mais vite fait je veux juste
leur dis pas rendre hommage à un groupe
qui fait c'est que il il explique la
croyance au père noël pourquoi enfin ils
se cherchent à les faire réfléchir sur
la croyance au père noël qui leur paraît
évidemment le ridicule tue et une maison
congo est exquis que bell pourtant il ya
des preuves entre guillemets tuer le
père noël tu peux l'appeler au téléphone
bientôt va ou non mais t'as envoie des
lettres tu vois tu as tes parents qui
font vachement autorités quand même tu
les vois posté la lettre tu as des tués
sur le truc peut paraît enfin non c'est
pas possible que ça n'existe pas
finalement tu reçois des cadeaux donc
votre preuve entre guillemets fin tu
vois et finalement l'idée se veut il se
sert de cette croyance là pour montrer
que bah finalement quand on apprend
enfin que quand on a tous cru à des
choses folles sans être fou non tu vas
en fait et et l'idée aussi c'est de dire
voilà quand on est un enfant et que
finalement on apprends moi je j'ai j'ai
trop peur du jour où ma fille ne croira
plus
parce que ce que j'aime trop calibre à
bombay parce que ça me fait rêver moi
même le jour où tu apprends que ça
n'existe pas assez chaud en fait c'est
compliqué tu tu vois quand fait honte à
petit tout mais quelque part ça te fait
grandir et tu es et tu deviens plus tu
deviens plus comment dire critique et tu
deviens plus est en fait s'ils gagnent
en fait au final tu vois ce que te dire
et en gros il se sert de cette espèce de
parallèle ce bon pour essayer de voir si
ça peut éventuellement raisonner avec
leur propre croyance aveugle tu vois
mais il ya plein de petites techniques
comme ça que je trouve assez intéressant
temps enfin moi ça m'a parce que des
fois dans tu vois avec l'association des
cov et où des france retrouve devant des
cas tu sais il ya tellement tout à
reprendre tu vois enfin il ya tellement
de tu te dis ok donc c'est pas c'est pas
avec ma petite inter de deux heures que
je vais que je vais réussir à le faire
atterrir et donc il ya quand même pas
mal de ouais pas mal de petits trucs là
que je pioche un peu là dedans qui me
qui me donne des idées mais donc voilà
tout ça pour dire que pareille gerin
braun r c'est quelqu'un pareil que j'ai
eu la chance maintenant de rencontrer
j'ai pris les caps a écrit machin etc
c'est ces gens mais parce que pareil ça
ça ne serait pas arrivé non plus je
pense donc donc je suis hyper contente
en fait de sarah malgré voilà les
difficultés parfois davantage éventuelle
exposition que j'aime pas trop et de
voilà donc là mais je suis plein de
choses mais le finalement bénéficient
les énormes donc donc c'est top pour
chaque donc je suis pas content je
pourrais quand ça financièrement alors
écoute donc moi je suis pigiste en fait
qu'est-ce que le pistent le pigiste mais
non mais en gros alors financièrement ça
va
je remercie d'ailleurs tous ceux qui
contribuent à mon tipi en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que je suis j'ai créé cette
chaîne donc sur mes propres petits
moyens pendant quasiment un an en fête
est un moment donné bungert je n'ai plus
financièrement et j'étais un peu prise
parce que à la fois j'avais plein de
gens qui commençaient à me dire tard
c'est chambéry est trop rigolo fraîcheur
2007 nana etc
c'est trop coup de la main j'avais pas
que ça mais j'en ai et est donc
encouragements quoi et puis en même
temps qu d'argent et et c'est à ce
moment là vraiment que france
télévisions manimal nous on va créer
notre jeunesse pour 18 35 et tout sur le
web
est ce que tu vas être un des visages
cette info jeunesse light ou et j'aurais
d'abord dit enfin que moi en tout cas je
tenais vraiment à être avoir le contrôle
total de ce que je fais et cetera d'un
éditorial mais les héros problème et on
dit mais en discutant et donc j'ai la
chance en fait depuis ce moment-là de
d'avoir ce programme donc que j'ai créée
qui est coproduit par france télé mais
c'est mais c'est des petits contrats
c'est à dire que c'est des petits cons
suis payé à la vidéo c'est des petits
contrats de trois mois là par exemple ça
vient de se signer là et puis dans deux
mois le contrat est déjà finie va
falloir essayer de renégocier rien dit
qui vont peut-être reprendre ou pas
reprendre donc ça reste quand même très
il ya beaucoup de ya beaucoup de phases
où en fait oui à pôle emploi donc et et
surtout j'ai aussi ouvert mon tipi parce
que parce que finalement j'ai déjà un je
trouve ça bien d'avoir si les gens et
voilà m un peu ce que je fais et on dit
de me soutenir dans ce que je fais c'est
aussi une manière d'être un tout petit
peu indépendante
tu vois d'avoir ne serait-ce qu'un mini
fonds de roulement à moi tout seul et
c'est sans forcément dépendre que ce
soit de français qui dot qui que ce soit
d'autre
et puis aussi parce que et ça c'est le
drame des journalistes c'est que trop
souvent tu te retrouves prise à la gorge
à devoir faire très vite très vite une
enquête simplement parce que tu as plus
de rentrées d'argent en fait et j'ai
plus envie d'être là dedans et parce que
c'est parce que c'est la porte ouverte à
toutes les troupes casse gueule et c'est
donc à un truc rapide de tuchan répit
moi j'ai plus envie de faire des trucs
rapide à la va-vite et cetera sainement
et donc en fait quelque part ce type là
les gens qui contribuent ils me voilà
entre deux contrats par exemple là
typiquement et des fois la période
d'ailleurs elle pas et elle peut être
plus ou moins longues entre deux
contrats tu je sais que j'ai un petit
soutien qui fait que je peux aussi
prendre le temps donc et de chercher il
avait approché une enquête et de
commencer à tu vois cc c'est bête mais
psychologiquement ça te ça changerait ça
change quand même pas mal l'adico donc
donc voilà donc après ça me met mal
parce que des fois j'ai gens qui disent
ah oui là je peux pas en ce moment parce
que le mythe
quand je sais plus j'ai des gens qui
m'ont contacté j'ai dit non mais c'est
c'est quoi me donne rien en fait
il ya des gens qui disent ah là je peux
pas parce que je suis endetté de chez
fashions la main mais le mois prochain
normalement je dois pouvoir qui les 5
euros et celle non mais non mais j'en ai
beaucoup d'émoi étudie non franchement
toi tu me donnes rien en fait
yara c'est quoi c'est gratuit pour toi
message du coup ça m'a mieux si des fois
un peu mal à l'aise puisque je veux pas
que les gens
enfin bon bref cc c'est un drôle de voix
mais je pense que malheureusement ou
enfin malheureusement j'en sais rien
mais tu vois je suis quand même super
contente que ce soit coproduit par
france télévisions parce que déjà ses
services publics
moi je trouve que enfin moi je m'inscris
vraiment dans cette espèce de truc de
service public fin j'ai vraiment vitrail
pour le service public
et puis et puis parce que je pense que
même avec du crowdfunding est tout jeune
ça coûte cher dans l'actuelle les
enquêtes que je fais ne serait-ce que
ben voila mon salaire le salaire de
l'enquêtrice le tout le montage le
tournage le 28 août tous les moyens je
sais pas je n'oublie encore des
milliards de trucs là qui font que ça va
quand même un sacré pourquoi ce que les
gens oublient aussi souvent c'est à dire
que la l'info la qualité de l'info elle
dépend aussi du prix du bitume est donc
parce que les gens sont habitués à voir
de l'info gratos et c'est parfois gratos
enfin bref il faut faire prendre
conscience aux gens aussi que ça a un
coût et donc je pense que s'il n'y avait
pas france tv ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué néanmoins de simplement de
produire ce que je fais et je j'en
profite aussi pour dire que je suis
super contente de faire ce programme
avec donc susanna lea qui est
productrice de ses productions et qui
croient dans un projet depuis le début
et qu'une super partenaire on s'entend
bien elle a aussi une elle a aussi une
association elle est présidente d'une
autre association s'appelle lumière sur
l'info qui fait à peu près la même chose
que nous peut-être une plus petite
échelle d'aller dans les bars bricolage
d'araignée tissée par le journalisme c
est donc on a pas vraiment on a un super
30ème quoi donc
donc finalement ça s'est bien goupillé
et moi je suis très je suis très
partisane de ce
duthu c'est du temps dont on verra bien
et là j'ai tenté ma au final tu vois que
des trucs cool ouais y'a normes biais de
sélection à ce que ceux que j'ai
interrogés disent à peu près ça alors
évidemment après c'est difficile de se
dire le contraire effectivement ça
s'appelle un biais de sélection de fois
tu m'apprends quelque chose c'est à dire
que tu vas dire que les gens que
j'essayais que j'ai interviewés sont
tous des gens qui ont réussi à oui bah
oui ce que dira oui seigneur existence
je sais pas mais bon après je dis pas
que j'ai soir réussi soit enfin bon bref
j'en sais rien sur celle encore une
grande session la réussite ou là mais en
tout cas en tout cas avoir des portes
que j'aurais jamais qu'il n'aurait
jamais été ouverte
autrement voilà ses larmes et adultes
atteints à savoir un modèle économique à
votre banon mais c'est un vrai problème
d'ailleurs enfin tu vois c'est c'est
bête mais une fois il ya des gens qui
m'ont fait remarquer arrêt non mais ça
c'est pour ça que ça montre aussi que
les gens comprennent pas mais je leur en
veux pas tu le mets finalement pourquoi
tu rationalise pas tu te mets devant
enfin tu genre en une journée et
enregistre trois vidéos et puis après tu
les fais mais ça se passe pas comme ça
en fait tu sais quand même pas il faut
pour une enquête
ouais si on les journées j'enregistrais
vidéo il faut mener ces neuf mois le
temps d'enquêter 3 3e et après je les ai
enfin c'est pas parce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est pas c'est pas comme un
sketch où un truc où tu ou quelque part
c'est surtout le talent d'écriture qui
compte mais après tu n'as pas besoin moi
pour la moindre enquête
là par exemple ça fait 15 jours que je
suis en attente
de discuter avec un mec si tu veux c'est
incompressibles ce genre de temps là je
peux pas et ce gars là il est
indispensable pour mon enquête donc donc
tu as un temps incompressible en fait de
l' enquête qui fait que fait que qui
fait que je peux pas comme ça puis c'est
de la copie tu vois que mon frère enfin
ce ne peut pas comme ça avoir un
rendement de folie en fait j'adorerais
je sais pas de quel est l'avenir ça
c'est une vraie question est la fois on
m'a demandé que mais dans 50 voudrait
tout
ouais j'ai aucune idée je sais je sais
que j'aimerais bien faire émerger
d'autres d'autres personnes tu vois mais
est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit sur ma
chaîne ou est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit
plutôt des toits d'autres journalistes
en fait évidemment aurait aussi un peu
leur style et qui feraient leur ça
j'aimerais bien mais je sais pas trop
comment
des fois je me dis sur ma chaîne c'est
compliqué enfin je sais pas je sais pas
trop par en tout cas moi je ne sais pas
du tout après jeu là cette année on a
décidé d'aller sur des gros complot des
grosses théorie du complot
donc on fait plus vraiment les petites
piques news etc va survivre au c ur du
complot et j'avoue que j'aimerais bien
pour les j'aimerais bien tous les faire
mais en mode des nerfs tu vois pendant
encore deux ans trois ans et peut-être
après je sortirai un peu d'effets news
je sais pas mais mais parce que des fois
je me dis mais c'est triste aussi tu
vois deux dans un monde empli mais
normal et sain et ces jeux devraient pas
être en train de de nettoyer entre
guillemets le caca des autres de ce côté
non mais des fois j'ai vu la femme de
ménage du web tu as exagère un peu et je
me lâche je maman j'ai un titre capable
mieux tu veux mais tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est que pendant que les gens
n'aillent sont mobilisés à débusquer des
trucs ils sont pas mobilisés sur va
faire des enquêtes de base en fait je
qui sont pas les enquêtes pour démasquer
un fait revivre en fait tu vois le la
société et c'est maintenant
mon xp d'empaqueter king parce que
tellement il ya de conneries mais est ce
que finalement enfin ça évidemment c'est
bien il faut etc mais mais moi ce qui
m'énerve c'est que dans un monde encore
mais normal ils devraient pas être là en
fait moi je moi je devrais enfin je
n'étais pas un calcul de ma vie de faire
ça j'aurai je devrais j'aimerais bien
être un peu comme par orange cars 2 dans
un monde normal je devrais être en train
de fermer un reportage normaux sur tel
ou tel scandale ou tel ou tel ou tel ou
tel truc j'irai peut être en train de
dire voilà alors c'est quoi la dernière
connerie du web
ouais ça c'est sur 40 sites cette daube
d'accord bon alors attendez quoi je vais
prendre trois mois de ma vie et puis je
manquais tu vois ces voix là je ne dis
pas que c'est pas de la ressource perdu
tout ce que je pense et hyper utile
parce que l'ajustement j'ai envie
justement je suis dans une logique un
peu de attaquons nous aux gros truc tu
vois j'ai pas envie de faire ça non plus
pendant 72 ans donc
attaquons nous aux intrus s'attaquer au
gros truc peut-être plus tard sa rentrée
jaunisse chez vous et non mais je suis
dans cette chute dans cette logique là
voilà mais des fois je regrette de
devoir faire ça non parce que pas parce
que ça me saoule ça m'amuse beaucoup ce
que je fais mais parce que parce que
voilà pendant que les forces sont
mobilisés sur premier des deux gâchettes
sont mobilisés sur sur d'autres les
ressources à son finish tu veux il n'ya
pas ira à toi les ressources d'un
potentat certain nombre de journalisme
de journalistes voilà et si tu as
maintenant la moitié j'exagère j'en sais
rien c'est évidemment pas la moitié qui
font du devens est ainsi c'est une
moitié qui et pas sur autre chose sur
des français quand balki au du coup il
la trompait pas enfin tu vois je n'en
sais rien mais voilà bref ouais après je
dis pas je fais pas trop de la
république non plus faire un tous les
tous les quatre matins avec eux
enfin ça veut pas dire que je rassure
des enquêtes de folie non plus si
j'étais si j'étais sûr j'étais pas sur
youtube mais ça m'interroge quoi voilà
ça ouais tu vois deux des bunkers des
mythes plutôt que de faire vivre un vrai
de vrai là dit si tu es quand même
c'est un fait nettoyés oui c'est toi et
d'ailleurs ça c'est un vrai voilà mais
on cherche des fois des sources de
financement à gauche à droite et tous et
je sais plus quelle était un organisme
assez intéressant allemand et tous qui
qui pouvait pas me financés parce que
j'ai dit oui non financent leurs
investigations tueur jamais moi je fais
ça des noms mais toi tu es sur les
clauses mais bon si oui ou non mais
voilà ça m'embête parce que chaque mois
six mois ces investigations plus
personne du doigt ce qu'il y aura une
évolution dans ta relation et quelques
journalistes depuis que ces tâches à
youtube il me demande tous comment ça va
mais est ce que tient le coup et c'est
une bonne question
on n'a jamais posé enfin ça pour dire
moi j'ai toujours eu de bonnes relations
avec les jambes maire gérald j'ai pas de
toi j'ai jamais vu j'ai pas de baby
schumi culié scène je dirais mais je
pense qu'il ya certains qui je pense
mais j'ai peur d'avancer pour eux ce
mais voilà quand on se voit dans
l'assaut et où la plupart je pense tous
que c'est quand même plutôt cool ce que
je fais ce qui me fait le plus plaisir
c'est quand il y en a certains qui me
disent que c'est courageux
alors ça ça peut tromper dire que je
considère pas ça non plus courageux mais
ça fait plaisir surtout longtemps et ma
relation avec eux n'ont ils sont un peu
curieux parce qu'en fait si l'ama est
quelqu'un de justement qui était dans
l'association qui m'a dit la dernière
fois mais de co2 en vrai ce que parce
que j'étais là en fait un copain caffin
superdogs historique et ces machins et
gta totalement admiratif de son boulot
et s'est retourné vers moi et m'a dit
mettez en fait
déjà tu as pas être admiratif quand tu
vois mon bref et surtout ce que tu fais
toi c'est ça l'avenir en fait non moi je
sais que ce que je fais c'est nul c'est
un peu de tout du passé nation et ça m'a
fait un peu de la place de la paix nous
tu vois j'ai de cela je pouvais pas dire
non c'est pas du tout l'avenir c'est pas
grave donc j'étais là ouais peut-être
c'est vrai ma chère mais voilà il
s'ennuie beaucoup sont dans ce
questionnement mais au questionnement
sur le futur du journalisme
ouais voilà tu vois il voit que fouad le
fait qu' a priori c'est un truc a l'air
de plutôt bien marché tu vois c'est un
appel de paris qui avait rien de base
par un parent un vrai pari ce que
ballard qui jusqu'ici marche à peu près
donc quelque part disent ah ouais donc
il ya moyen de faire autre chose que ce
que je fais là mais mais comment quoi
etc
ouais souvent oui la relation n'a pas
changé dans le sens où tu veux en des
chants des relations saines et amicales
mais avec tout le monde etc
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont assez
curieuse de voir comment ça se passe sur
le web
mais voilà ses ouailles à ces
questionnements là et puis comment et
puis il ya la question aussi de
commander effectivement comment tu
comment tu l'envi bas et eux ils savent
ils connaissent les rouages donc un
français les machins mais je pense que
beaucoup auraient envie d'innover aussi
à ce niveau là il ya des gars ya
d'ailleurs des podcasts qui s'appelle
jean piot gim kallio j'avais fait il
s'était dit trop mignons ils m'avaient
interviewé pour leur premier podcast qui
qui explore justement tous les
journalistes qui qui essayent d'inventer
en fait donc des nouvelles des nouvelles
façons de parler aux gens des nouvelles
et c'est vachement intéressant ils ont
souvent des trucs super invités comme
moi et est en fête
wei voilà en général voilà la relation
pas tellement changé si ce n'est que ça
que je fais ce site une certaine
curiosité quoi ouais tiens elle fait ça
ouais c'est que ça a l'air de marcher je
disais aussi tcdd cognitif
oui oui mais c'était passionnant à la
dernière fois j'ai fait donc je suis
devenu un peu par ma copine entre
guillemets avec donc ce albert
moukheiber on a pris deux trois cafés et
tout je vais proposer de les proposer de
venir
je trouvais ça tellement intéressant ski
que j'ai dit c'est quoi toi fais ça tu
vois je voudrais que tu sors en face des
journalistes de mon bateau on discute en
fait n'avait été devons amorcer un
espèce de gamberge en fait vu très sympa
il m'a dit n'ai aucun problème et tout
est donc on s'est vus la semaine
john rishton alors on n'est pas donc les
1001 on est et puis alors pour que pour
rassembler les gens c'est toujours il y
en a un qui est partie en série en mach
1 donc on est là on était des genres
entre 10 et 15 sur le maximum et du cou
et du coup voilà il a parlé pendant une
heure de de plein de choses pas que des
biais cognitif de de la démocratie de ce
qui fait que fin de deux des billets
aussi dans les médias de cela et c'était
silence de mort tout le monde écoute et
tu vois à fond notez tout donc j'étais
déjà super contente et on l'a filmé pour
nous mais c'est je pense que c'est pour
nous c'est pour nous peut-être notre
dans berges interne on mettra peut-être
je ne sais pas mais enfin bon je donc
pas de m'être donnée par là et est
et ils sont tous ressortis de là et ça
m'a vachement plaisir avec avec plein de
radars notamment qui a dit qu est-ce qui
est sandro il a dit un truc du style
mais en fait je sais plus exactement
comme il l'a dit mais c'était c'était un
peu mais en fait on fait on a tout faux
en fait c'était pas ça le cimentant mais
c'était c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment en fait sont sortis avec un
gros questionnement sur comment sur les
médias sur ce qui fonctionne pas dans
les médias
[Musique]
ils m'ont tous dit après on va et
d'électro et tous hyper intéressant
albert ça me fait vachement réfléchir au
soleil ouais c'est super forte
bon eh ouais il est donc et donc et donc
tu vois sont tous ressortis en disant ah
ouais c'est quand même un peu une classe
là c'est tu vois par exemple il disait
il y avait une journaliste l'aso qui
disent aimer tu vois le problème c'est
que quand on va voir notre rédacteur en
chef sur telle ou telle thématique et
qu'on me propose deux intervenants il va
vouloir celui qui est le plus quelqu'un
de l'union la plus tranché ouais
en tout cas plaint pas forcément toute
polémique c'est certain mais celui qui à
l'opinion la plus tranché la plus est
celui qui va être plus dans la nuance et
paris ce travail y sera moins ou un prix
tu vas et halle berry dit bah ouais
c'est un problème est là bon ok ça non
mais tu vois c'est là que celui des
petites graines on va dire ouais donc
mais j'aimerais bien reconduire ce genre
de trucs
répondre seulement des petits rendez
vous régulièrement pourquoi pas il à
agir d'ailleurs parce que là c'était les
journalistes de mon association au final
tous les journalistes ont battu de 2/100
donc avoir voilà c'était une petite
tentative fois que je faisais déjà j'ai
juste parce que je l'espère encore écrit
j'ai proposé de devenir parler de ça
mais c'est vrai que en tout cas ça
voilà ça ça sème un peu des petites
graines comme ça après je sais pas ce
que ça peut éventuellement donner ou pas
mais je trouve ça bien voilà je trouve
ça bien de décès de partager un peu ça
d'avoir cet échange là et puis
d'ailleurs c'était je pense intéressant
c'est pour lui parce que parce que tu as
envie aussi emmener de l'oci en publiant
blazy qu'est-ce que tu ferais tu as ma
place toi c'est pas ça non mais ces
bandits français coincés dans ce système
là et que tu essaies tu vois voilà
c'était la cité affaire est sûre vous
mettre plein fouet
il n'y a pas la solution d'ailleurs mais
si les partenaires français publics et
oui moi par exemple je me suis retrouvé
à faire un reportage je n'en dirai pas
plus ou mon rédacteur en chef mais
j'essayais d'expliquer la complexité des
choses que c'était pato de l'entonnoir
et c est mon rédacteur en chef de
l'époque m'a quand même dit c'est quoi
il est où le gentilé ou de méchants il
faut que ce soit clair dans l'esprit des
gens sinon personne va comprendre ton
sujet j'arrête
tu vois et là j'étais vachement
désarçonné quoi parce que c'est chaud
que tu me répondras salé aux lentilles
ou de méchants jamais arrivé une fois ça
mais tu te dis en fait ces gens là la
kippa sur les les biais cognitif et où
il faudra les mettre en face des
rédacteurs en chef possible à toi un peu
plus aulas est en phase d tu as et en
face des gens un peu plus mais ça va
venir je vais manger heures mais tu veux
mais tu vois ces chants poèmes dans
comme un truc pareil tu vois et
effectivement en plus ça ne simplifie la
vie
en terme de montage parce qu'il te reste
plus que deux jours de montage parce que
tu as m6 qui vient visionner ton truc
dans deux jours et que tu vois donc
battu va faire le gentil de mes chansons
c'est quoi après les jantes appel une
fois la diffusion du sujet et que pour
ici te disent mais vous avez fait
n'importe quoi c'est les choses sont
plus complexes que ça et toi tu es là tu
fais tu sais quoi je suis enfin chacun
raison et je suis désolé mais c'est
horrible mais ça ne s'est pas passé
comme ça parce que j'ai défendu un peu
le sujet etc
on a réussi à trouver des compromis mais
tu vois la difficulté pour ça je pense
que ça se passe comme dans beaucoup de
et puis évidemment à la demande de temps
le monde entier en faveur de ces gens de
bien la préparer leur bien sûr sinon par
le même preuve avec google et youtube
voilà particulier c'est que j'aimerais
que youtube france combien bénéfique
comme ça et j'ai pas accès aux managers
aux gens qui décident que par contre je
pense avoir accès un peu certains jeunes
des seniors c'est bien mais tu connais
guillaume chanudet interview est
d'ailleurs très bien a bon d'accord je
lis est un ancien donc servi aussi un
mousse et bien sûr nos paisibles au cas
où tu le vois je suis d'accord donc
ouais voilà il faut essayer de fait ce
qu'on peut un jour a aussitôt demandé
que quelqu'un qu'elle fut ta réaction
par rapport à nos fonctions alors en
fait je suis dégoûté parce que nos
sections alors première réaction que
j'ai eue c'était que c'était un mauvais
timing pour communiquer parce que ces
sorties genre en juillet le truc moi ce
que j'avais la tête comme ça je te bord
de la piscine
maintenant que l'on pouvait plus être
donnée donc
j'ai fait c'est quoi ça on va le garder
donc j'espère beaucoup s'en sortent ça
en termes de tempo médiatique si vous
êtes élu a purement et ensuite ensuite
en fait ça m'a ça m'a interpellé mais
j'ai écouté il y avait une émission sur
france culture dans laquelle il était
invité
ouais je les écoutais après j'avais tu
vois de là tu me fais penser à ça
j'avais envoyé un ou deux messages
justement à des jeux s'est plu à des
représentants d'une infection c'est tout
pour qu'on se rencontre
parce qu'en fait par téléphone et ou moi
ça me semble enfin cela qu'on se voie et
puis il ya comme ça des trois tentatives
avortées de foncer en a jamais fait tu
vois pas ce que en vrai j'avais besoin
d'eux j'ai besoin de m'asseoir aux
redoutables et qu'on discute qu'on
comprenne qu'on regarde mais ça
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que mais j'ai
du coup j'ai pas vraiment les j'ai
compris qu'elle un fusil ouais mais je
sais ce que j'aimerais faire par exemple
c'est mais je sais pas encore si ses
fins je sais pas ce sera possible mais
par exemple un reportage que nous faire
un typiquement qui est qui est
problématique a priori protection a
priori je dis bien parce que moi j'ai
tendance à défendre les journalistes
aussi
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien faire se rencontrer le
journaliste en question et quelques uns
de nos sections devant devant ce
reportage là et mais je n'aimais pas
filmé par rien tu vois j'ai pas envie
que ça veut que les gens se mettre dans
des postures ou des trucs à la con mais
juste là où on est tu vois avoir vu le
journaliste et puis il ya une élection
juste de manière dépassionnée discuter
comprendre en fait tu vois que mais je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas fait je n'ai pas
organisé et puis on n'a pas les donc
j'ai vu c'est pas grand chose à dire
d'autre que ça tu veux ça m'a l'air
effectivement m contre yb problématiques
après j'avais échangé avec gérald
bronner là dessus jma et parler
notamment des leaf aux as et c'est qu'à
l'air d'être là mais je sais pas j'ai
pas voilà j'ai eu je peux pas dire
d'autre chose que voilà j'ai pas encore
vu cette espèce de rendez vous avec
l'infection s'est d'ailleurs il faut que
je relance où je comprendrais un peu les
tenants et les aboutissants mais entre
ce qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que
c'est que je pense qu'il n'y a pas assez
tueur analyse camp de formation
scientifique c'est fait mais ça c'est
enfin je pense pas trop m'avancer en
disant ça costumes c'est au contraire
souvent plus et littéraire enfin souvent
tout va ce qui ne veut pas dire que tu
es moche et hyper pas scientifique
et je dis pas que je faire un travail
j'ai dû tout sentiment de qualité
extrême footing tous mais ses parents
parce que j'ai plein de gens qui ne
savent rien de la méthode scientifique
chez les humanistes ces voies de fait
qui est touché je suis la france chez
sfr j'ai une méthode scientifique
non mais tu vois je sais pas en fait
c'est comme quoi la science se cache pas
mais mais mais j'ai pas voilà j'ai je
sais qu'il n'ya pas je pense que
malheureusement j'ai il faut que je veux
pas parler sans savoir donc mais
j'imagine que en tout cas la tendance
elle est le biais il est assez aisément
compris quand c'est pas il ya une étude
tout un peuple qui sort et qui parle
d'un scandale le journaliste d'office a
plutôt envie de creuser là dessus et
peut-être que du coup il ya des billets
qui ce qui se met en place à vouloir d
alors il ya autre chose aussi qu'elle
est compliquée qu'il faut essayer de
comprendre
mais à quoi deux fois là je ne veux pas
moi je le jure il faudrait connaître un
mot bien le dossier etc
mais ça arrive aussi d'être retrouvé au
milieu d'une enquête
et tout d'un coup patatras tu vois que
finalement ton truc ne tient plus
tellement la route plus tellement tu
vois pas qu'est ce tu fais parce que le
problème parce que là encore problèmes
financiers en fait quand tu fais un
quand tu fais une enquête typiquement
moi mon inculture expérimentations
animales saadi du rugby mois bon tu es
payé au forfait c'est à dire qu'en fait
on te paye de manière assez classique on
te paye six mois est en fait après on
estime que six hauts de lahti moi ton
enquête elle dure c'était pour le mans
angers jean danis tout contretemps sans
mal et qu'il y est il est très souvent
il faut vraiment avoir du talent pour
pleurer pour avoir des pour avoir pour
qui te rajoute un peu de salaire pour la
farce yeux donc ça arrive souvent là que
la fente la fille sont en pole on passe
tout le temps le tout ça c'est aussi un
problème et donc du coup comme desserrer
que tu as cette deadline et que ton truc
c'est sûr que dans 4 semaines il devrait
être rendu
ouais ouais qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas
pas t'asseoir sûreté neuf semaines août
à creuser un trou où au final tu
t'aperçois que c'était peut-être pas été
oubliée tricoter un truc là dessus et je
n'ai je dis pas ça pour défendre la fin
j'ai encore une fois c'était juste dire
l'idée de comprendre humainement ce qui
se passe à ce moment là ce
la tête d'un bruit c'est très compliqué
donc tu vas peut-être utilisé des mots
effectivement moins fort où tu vas
peut-être machin mais tu vas tu vas en
général difficilement passeport
complètement tu veux sur ton
ou alors si tu le fais c'est très bien
mais tu va galérer je vais tenir à
repartir de zéro alors que ça fait deux
mois que tu es dessus et c'est ton truc
tu vas mettre fin dans tu vas finir dans
les choux total financière donc ça joue
aussi peut-être tu vois c'est compliqué
en gros je ne sais pas cheap les
enquêtes envoyé spécial sais pas combien
de temps ils ont à mon avis c'est du
deux mois et demi pour sortir un sujet
tu pointes comme ça un peu comme les
oiseaux fait que je pense
et ben voilà au bout de chez pas au bout
de 15 jours maximum il faut que tu sache
exactement à peu près où tu vas aller
parce que ses fins en gros j'exagère un
peu tu veux c'est pas tellement ça sais
c'est qu'en tout cas voilà c'est du coup
ça ça rend compliqué le fait de le fait
de changer son fusil d'épaulé
tout d'un coup on donnait au dessus de
toi d'où l'importance effectivement de
partir ceux des super bonnes bases
scientifiques ce problème je ne sais pas
je franchement et puis je ne dis pas que
j'aurais été mieux que franchement les
sujets incriminé par excellence je sais
pas ces points que se pose aussi en
sciences
ouais ça souvent que les gens fassent
une expérience moi samara d'y arriver
qu'un mathématicien
bon moi tu veux dire c'est moins grave
encore que 10 mois j'ai pris tel
théorème est ce que je veux pas
réfléchir à quoi il sert et après on
raconte une histoire par dessus
évidemment le truc on m'accepte être pas
trop denses à son tour sa pique nique
ans et des expériences scientifiques qui
peuvent être interprétées de mille et
une manières non non résultat tu peux
fabriquer une histoire vraiment j'ai
même fait le plus montré mon sujet sur
l'expérimentation animale
je crois que j'ai un dvd là donc je
t'aurais que je me demande c'est un
homme et sa main en fait c'est quand
j'ai vu une infection
j'ai dit j'espère qu'ils penseraient que
je sais pas ce qu'ils penseraient de mon
sujet sur les chercheurs qui vont pas
dire c'est de la daube mais je vous
montrais justement je parlais du modèle
animal et je je je m'entraîne
justement je parlais des billets c'est à
dire que je me suis rendu compte avec
effarement dans cette dans ce sujet que
plein de publications scientifiques qui
sont censés le thème des publications
sérieuse ne respectez pas je croyais à
trois critères il ya le blinding et le
chic ou quoi je me rappelle il ya en
gros il ya trois critères qui font que
si tu utilises passé trois critères
entre d'expérience ça veut pas dire ces
photos expérience mais n'a pas pris les
tapas t'as pas appliquer des trucs
l'aîné
comment dire comment devenir boxée box
n'étaient pas aussi rigoureux voilà et
j'étais allé voir un chercheur écossais
remède génial
malcom mc leod qui avait bossé là dessus
et qui dit prenez tout épineuse et ça
c'est zéro ça il a fait un critère sur
trois ans ok ça va jamais des trucs qui
étaient dans des grosses robuste humaine
mais je suis à notre équipe et du coup
pour décrire votre animal moi j'avais
extrapolé ça en dix ans enfin montrant
aussi le gâchis ça pouvait représenter
aussi en termes d'animaux tu veux quand
tu sais même pas pour des études qui
sont rigoureuses enfin c'est qu'on met
une pression c'est difficile où ai je
dit pas comme d'ailleurs tu vois là on
parle de journalisme et je suis enfin
parler tous les problèmes qui ont dit
non et c mais pardon voilà messieurs
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien le le
passé au grill de du jugement du
mouvement nos sections c'est mon sujet
juste pour voir si j'aimerais que je
peux le regarder à dire ce que la vraie
je crois que je il sembla dvd par contre
je suis pas d'hector dvd
voilà une goutte d'eau mais dis-moi kéba
machine raclée de question que je suis
si tu veux est ce qu'il y a s'il ya un
message c'est que tu aimerais que les
auditeurs obtiennent un truc
journalistes c'est trop c'est trop cool
c'est dans ce métier c'est vrai en plus
c'est c'est passionnant le tu rentres
dans des dents défunt on va essayer la
de faire vivre un peu mon enquête j'ai
fait un petit carnet de bord de mes
enquêtes là je sais pas ce que ça va
donner mais le journalisme c'est vrai
que c'est très critique et ces images
qui parlent enfin parfois à tort pour x
raisons quand même souvent un peu comme
avec manière exagérée à tort et et mon
avis mais mais en fait c'est un métier
passionnant et moi je le jour cela fait
du bien parce que j'ai rencontré j'ai
fait une petite compte dans un
amphithéâtre et d'un coup je demande qui
veut être journaliste et j'ai vu plein
de doit se lever et à la fois disait à
la fois ça m'a fait trop plaisir à la
fois disais pas va falloir qui
s'accroche bien mais mais mais ça fait
plaisir parce que ces champs mais en
fait moi j'ai pour la réhabilitation du
journalisme même pas comme un mode de
vie c'est-à-dire navire se baser sur les
faits en fait c'est rien d'autre que ça
ouais c'est juste se baser sur les faits
et s'est écrasé les choses parfois pour
argent comptant tout qu'on te donne tu
vois et en fait quand tu creuses c'est
pas seulement parce que c'est ce que
j'explique souvent aux jeunes quand j'ai
quand je vais dans l'intervention jeu
mais moi il me demande pourquoi vous
être contre votre métier qu'est ce qui
est intéressant dans ce métier tout
j'aime ce que j'adore c'est qu'en fait
des trucs sur lesquels pour le coup j'ai
souvent des a priori puisque tu en as
des a priori quand tu te retrouves à
travailler dessus
tu te rends compte qu'en fait c'est
mille fois plus compliqué que ce que tu
imaginais en et c'est passionnant et
j'essaye de j'essaye de leur transmettre
un peu ce n'est pas le sien
ce goût de si génial quand c'est
compliqué ouais bah ça c'est non mais tu
vois ses portes
bah sinon sinon c'est pas et on n'a qu'à
mourir tout de suite génial pour c'est
compliqué et c'est génial de réfléchir
tout en matière est ce que j'ai pas mal
logés et c est si génial en fait enfin
moi je trouve que c'est une chance
inouïe pour le coup est donc et ça c'est
le journal c'est aussi donc
donc c'est génial parce que je pourrais
finir aussi avec des recommandations de
vidéos podcasts livres ou personnes à
suivre ces attaques m oulala alors
attends l'agenda du score ces gens
l'oublient genre bonne ça va être des
gens que tu connais un recommandations
julie à ghallef ah oui au fait arrêter
ici tout joli agalev je veux quelqu'un
qui soit scripteur jeu les gars lève je
suis prête à payer à verser un peu de
mon tipi diaghilev
ce que je veux vraiment c'est quelqu'un
qui mérite d'être suivie mais puissance
12 et je recommande en particulier sa
vidéo sur l'honnêteté intellectuelle
julie à galets fils télé tu es loin
nestea c'est juste enfin pour moi c'est
la claque c'est la plaque genre du
trimestre peut-être de l'année quoi
voilà je peux revenir sur elle il ya un
livre qu'elle est qu'elle va avoir écrit
quand rentrée que la wii mais elle
commence justement ça en disant je suis
en train d'écrire un bouquin et cet
héritage donc j'attends trop calme cette
wave elle explique en fait pour résumer
très rapidement que on réfléchit trop en
mode soldats et que en fait même pour
notre propre intérêt
il faut qu'on réfléchisse en le mode
éclaireurs je crois que je dirais scout
c'est en mode éclaireurs c'est à dire un
mode c'est quoi je vais essayer de
trouver vraiment c'est je vais essayer
de rapporter les faits même si j'ai
envie que finalement le scénario se
passe de telle ou telle manière etc etc
je ne donne plus de deux importantes à
ce qu'il en est vraiment et est en fait
s'appuyer 25 ans raconte notamment que
les gens qui sont câblés un peu comme ça
qu'ils agissent comme ça ils s'en
sortent mieux globalement j'extrapole un
peu mais dans la vie parce que tout
simplement ils ont des ils sont capables
d'anticiper de manière beaucoup plus
juste des événements ils sont capables
de répondre
et comme ils acceptent aussi le fait de
cette plante et ils sont capables
d'ajuster un peu leur modèle de pensée
et cetera second telle ou telle manne
est en fait c'est juste plus intelligent
et plus fin voilà pour c'est génial dans
ces brillants donc voilà donc je peux
aller voir gibier qu'elle lève je
raconte mais je serais mal
les vidéos dans les casiers à albert
montcalivert toutes les vidéos avec
gérald bronner enfin toute la dream team
je reconnais pas assez d'autres mais je
vais y en avoir plein d'autres il ya
aussi olivier bougeant ses comptes
journaliste je trouve ça pas mal parce
que c'est vraiment en fait le postulat
cvs contre tous courants fait pour
accepter de travailler comme ça pour une
misère et c est ce qu on est tout ce
qu'on voit c'est un peu une occasion
peut-être connaître tous répond je ne
sais pas et puis des gens à suivre et ba
ba fola et sam sam mais mr sam des faits
14 complot facile que j'adore le le
pauvre j'ai pas une chaîne youtube c'est
un court mais qui est juste on vaque à
mourir de rire en fait voilà il vomit la
galère avec sa page facebook
dernièrement j'ai passé un ou deux
petits coups de fil à un service presse
et du coup il dit que c'est grâce à moi
qu'il a récupéré mais je pense pas
sincèrement c'est juste un truc
bon bref on s'en fout mais donc complot
facile pour briller en société vous
c'est sûr que vous allez briller en
société il ya qu'est ce que je regarde
c'est le forum
je crois avoir fait près tout ok bah je
sois j'espère surtout une chose mais
jeudi à calais la gamme de caméras
merci avec plaisir merci beaucoup mode
et pour les auditeurs je vous dis à
projets une fois probablement y est
merci à tout le monde tous ceux qui ont
tenu ce podcast jusqu'au bout